welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford School of Medicine
today we are discussing MDMA sometimes
referred to as ecstasy or Mali MDMA
stands for methylene dioxy
methamphetamine that's right you heard
the word methamphetamine in there and
MDMA has properties similar to
methamphetamine but also properties that
are very distinct from methamphetamine
just as a side note methamphetamine is a
commonly used drug of abuse it is an
illicit drug and it produces some of the
greatest and fastest increases in the
neuromodulator dopamine of any available
drugs on the street or in the clinic and
believe it or not methamphetamine is
prescribed as a prescription drug in
some very limited clinical uses
MDMA methylene dioxy methamphetamine has
properties similar to methamphetamine in
that it powerfully promotes the release
of dopamine and it is a stimulant and
yet it also powerfully controls the
release of Serotonin and in doing so
makes MDMA a distinct category of
compound from either classic
psychedelics like psilocybin or LSD
which largely work on the serotonin
system and tend to produce mystical
experiences and it's also distinct from
Pure stimulants such as methamphetamine
because MDMA by producing big increases
in both dopamine and serotonin acts as
what's called an empathogen it actually
can increase one sense of Social
connectedness and empathy not just for
other people but for oneself and in that
way MDMA is commonly used as a
recreational drug but also is now being
tested and is a achieving incredible
early results in clinical trials for its
use as an empathogen for the treatment
of PTSD in clinical therapeutic settings
I want to be very clear that at this
point in time June 2023 MDMA is still a
schedule one drug that is it is highly
illegal to possess or sell in the United
States and today we are going to talk
about some of the path to legality
that's underway we are also going to
talk about the history of MDMA and why
it became illegal and we are going to
talk about the key difference between
recreational use and therapeutic use and
the important components of the studies
exploring MDMA in the clinical setting
for the treatment of PTSD so during
today's discussion we will talk about
what MDMA really is how it works at the
level of neurons which brain circuits it
activates and deactivates and in doing
so you will come to understand why it is
so exciting as a treatment for PTSD will
you will also of course talk about the
results of of these clinical trials
using MDMA for the treatment of PTSD
they are incredibly exciting in fact the
field of Psychiatry has never before
seen the kind of success in treatment of
PTSD with any other compound that they
are seeing and achieving with the
appropriate safe use of MDMA and when I
say appropriate that means in
conjunction with nine therapy sessions
so this is an area that really deserves
some time for us to discuss because
again there is a distinct difference
between the recreational and the
therapeutic use of MDMA we will also
talk about the toxicity of MDMA this is
a very important issue because many of
you have perhaps heard that MDMA quote
unquote puts holes in your brain or
kills serotonin neurons or kills
dopamine neurons and indeed MDMA because
of its similarity to methamphetamine
which is highly neurotoxic MDMA can be
neurotoxic however there are ways to use
MDMA therapeutically that avoid avoid
its toxicity and yet there are still
questions about its toxicity and its
long-term effects both after acute use
meaning just one to three times as well
as chronic use meaning people who have
taken it many many times we'll talk
about the spacing between sessions of
MDMA we will talk about dosages we will
also talk about things that people do
and that can be done to offset some of
the potential toxicity of MDMA so by the
end of today's discussion you will have
a thorough understanding of what MDMA is
what it isn't what is known about what
it does
what is known about what it doesn't do
as well as some of the still outstanding
questions about MDMA that remain to be
resolved before we begin I'd like to
emphasize that this podcast is separate
from my teaching and research roles at
Stanford it is however part of my desire
and effort to bring zero cost to
Consumer information about science and
science related tools to the general
public in keeping with that theme I'd
like to thank the sponsors of today's
podcast our first sponsor is Helix sleep
Helix sleep makes mattresses and pillows
that are the absolute highest quality I
started sleeping on a helix mattress
over two years ago and since starting to
sleep on a helix mattress I've had the
best sleep of my life and that's because
the mattress is tailored to my unique
sleep needs everybody has unique sleep
needs and if you go to the Helix website
you can take a very brief two minute
quiz we'll ask you questions such as do
you tend to sleep on your back your side
or your stomach are you somebody who
tends to run warm or cold during the
night Etc perhaps you don't know the
answers to those questions that's fine
you can simply put that response and
Helix will match you to a mattress
that's ideal for your sleep needs this
is so critical because sleep is the
foundation of mental health physical
health and performance and when we are
sleeping well consistently everything in
life goes that much better and when we
are not sleeping well consistently
everything suffers there's a ton of
science to support those statements so
if you're interested in upgrading your
mattress go to helixsleep.com huberman
take their two-minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress and you'll get up to 350 off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
again if you're interested you can go to
helixsleep.com huberman for up to 350
off and two free pillows today's episode
is also brought To Us by Roca Roca
Mike's eyeglasses and sunglasses that
are the absolute highest quality the
company was founded by two All-American
swimmers from Stanford and everything
about Roca eyeglasses and sunglasses
were designed with performance in mind
I've spent a lifetime working on the
biology the visual system and I can tell
you that your visual system has to
contend with an enormous number of
different Channel challenges in order
for you to be able to see clearly Roka
understands those challenges and has
designed their eyeglasses and sunglasses
accordingly so that you always see with
perfect clarity their eyeglasses and
sunglasses were initially designed for
sports performance and as a consequence
they are very lightweight which is great
they also won't slip off your face if
you get sweaty however even though they
were designed for sports performance
they now also include a lot of styles
that are designed to be worn to work out
to dinner essentially recreationally so
that you could wear anywhere if you'd
like to try Roca eyeglasses or
sunglasses go to Roka that's roka.com
and enter the code huberman to save 20
off your order again that's Roca
roka.com and enter the code huberman at
checkout today's episode is also brought
To Us by hvmn Ketone IQ Ketone IQ is a
ketone supplement that increases blood
ketones I know most people are familiar
with or at least have heard of the
so-called ketogenic diet it's used for
weight loss it's used to control
epilepsy it's used for mental health
reasons however most people including
myself do not follow a ketogenic diet
nonetheless increasing your blood
ketones can improve the function of your
brain and the function of your body and
that's because ketones are preferred use
of fuel for the brain and body so even
though I follow an omnivore diet that is
I'm not in a ketogenic State I use
Ketone IQ to increase my blood ketones
prior to doing preparation for podcasts
or writing grants or doing research as
well as prior to workouts especially if
I want to work out fasted I'll take some
Ketone IQ to increase my blood ketones
which gives me a lot of energy during
workouts or during bouts of cognitive
work even if I haven't eaten in the
preceding hours it really increases my
focus and my energy levels if you'd like
to try Ketone IQ you can go to hvmn.com
huberman to save 20 off again that's
hvmn.com huberman to save 20 let's talk
about MDMA MDMA or ecstasy is a
fascinating compound and I say
fascinating from the perspective of its
chemical structure which is highly
unusual
I say fascinating because it has an
incredible set of subjective effects in
terms of how it makes people feel and it
has a fascinating history so let's just
briefly start with the history of MDMA
MDMA was synthesized by the drug company
Merck in the early 1900s but it actually
was never applied to any particular
clinical use and it wasn't really
explored much in any Laboratories at all
and then it was later rediscovered by a
guy named Alexander shulgin
who was a bit of a renegade drug chemist
who was designing different drugs for
the purpose of understanding their
subjective effects on humans so there's
a long history of Shogun designing drugs
he was after all a chemist and then
taking those drugs himself and then if
he liked the effects of a particular
drug or rather if he thought that it had
potential clinical utility he would give
it to his wife then she would give him
her notes about those drugs and then
they would share them with their friends
and it was a small group of friends who
consisted of therapists and Physicians
so this was a really underground kind of
operation it was technically not illegal
when it started because MDMA wasn't
illegal when it started but over the
several decades that Shogun and his wife
and this group were doing this kind of
exploration MDMA did become illegal and
he fell under well let's just say
scrutiny by the DEA
now here's the important thing to
understand about MDMA and its history
first of all
MDMA is a synthetic compound as far as
we know it does not exist anywhere in
nature so unlike similar compounds such
as mescaline because MDMA and masculine
are very similar in their chemical
properties and to some extent their
subjective properties
unlike mescaline which can be found in
the plant kingdom or LSD which comes
from ergot or psilocybin which of course
can be found in magic mushrooms MDMA is
a unique chemical in that again as far
as We Know
only exists in its synthetic form it is
human made and as we get into the
chemical effects and the subjective
effects of MDMA a little bit later in
the episode I think you'll understand
why it is such a unique and to some
extent exciting compound from the
perspective of clinical treatment put
differently there's really no other
compound that we know of in nature or in
the pharmaceutical industry shelf or
options of drugs that are prescription
drugs that produce the kinds of effects
that MDMA does and by the way if you're
interested in the story of Alexander
Shogun and the drugs he synthesized and
the group that he built up to take these
drugs and try them and actually had
several members of this group using
these drugs in therapy with their
patients
for a long period of time both before
and after MDMA became illegal
there's a wonderful book called pikal
that stands for
p-i-k-h-a-l p call is the title of the
book which Shogun wrote which describes
his discovery of MDMA I confess it also
describes the synthesis of MDMA and for
that reason was a book that for a long
time was not available but is now
available again in audible form and in
printed form pcall stands for
phenylethylamines I have known and loved
phenylethylamines is the category of
drug for which MDMA belongs to and it's
a long book but a very interesting one
both from the perspective of
understanding the history of MDMA and
what MDMA is and the effects that it
produces but it's also an interesting
book because it will teach you a lot
about the history of the pharmaceutical
industry the War on Drugs in the United
States and the interaction between
illegal drug exploration and drugs for
clinical treatment of psychiatric
challenges so right now this is a very
important issue because MDMA is
currently granted breakthrough status
which means it's now something that
scientists and clinicians can study if
they have authorization to do that it is
as I mentioned earlier still a schedule
on drugs so it's illegal to possess
unless you are one of these scientists
who has been granted permission to study
it in the clinical setting or the
laboratory setting and right now we are
on the cusp of MDMA becoming legal but
again it is not yet legal and this is
something I'm going to touch back on a
few times during today's episode
later for instance when we talk about
the potential toxicity of MDMA its
ability potentially to kill neurons
the neurons it has been hypothesized to
kill are neurons of the serotonin and
dopamine type so this is something you
would not want let's just recall that
killing off of or death of dopamine
neurons is the underlying basis for
Parkinson's Disease which is a movement
disorder where people have difficulty
generating smooth movements and in very
severe form they can't move at all they
sort of become locked in to some extent
and it also has cognitive effects so you
don't want to lose dopamine neurons and
loss of serotonergic neurons is known to
impact mood negatively mood regulation
negatively Etc
the story of MDMA and its potential
neurotoxicity comes slam right up
against this issue of legality and what
we'll get into a little bit later is
that there has been a sort of race in
the scientific Community consisting of
two groups one set of groups trying to
establish the toxicity of MDMA so that
it does not become legal again and
another group trying to establish the
utility and the lack of toxicity in MDMA
so that it does become legal again for
the treatment of PTSD so even though the
story P call relates to events that took
place largely in the 1970s 80s and 90s
right now MDMA and its toxicity or lack
of toxicity its legality or lack of
legality are really key issues so as
you're listening to this I'm giving you
a real-time blow-by-blow of what led up
to where we are now but we will also
want to think about how what's happening
right now including the description of
these data on MDMA may or may not impact
the potential legal status of MDMA okay
so what is MDMA MDMA is 3 4 methylene
dioxy methamphetamine but unless you're
a chemist that's not going to mean much
to you nor should it
MDMA has some very interesting
properties the first of which is that
methamphetamine component which because
it's a methamphetamine and acts like
other amphetamines what it does is it
blocks the reuptake of dopamine from
neurons after dopamine is released so
for those of you that heard the episode
that I did on drugs to treat ADHD I
discussed the biology and mechanisms of
drugs like Adderall and Vyvanse which
basically are either combinations of
amphetamines or single types of
amphetamines that have either a quick
release or a long release
now MDMA because it has this
methamphetamine component prevents the
reuptake of dopamine and in doing so
creates net increases in dopamine so for
those of you that don't have a
background in neurobiology let me just
briefly explain I'll make this very
simple neurons or nerve cells release
chemicals at their sites of
communication which are called synapses
synapses are little gaps between neurons
and what happens is the neurons spit out
these little spherical balls which we
call vesicles or vesicles depending on
where in the world you live they'll
either be called vesicles or vesicles
and those little vesicles contain
neurotransmitter or what's technically
referred to as a neuromodulator dopamine
is a neuromodulator can modulate the
activity of other neurons it can either
increase or decrease the activity of
other neurons now at the end of the
neuron that what we call the axonal
Bouton okay axon is the wire component
of the neuron that can reach to another
side in the brain and then release the
neurotransmitter or neuromodulator there
at those axonal boutons which are the
sites of release
the vesicles literally fuse with the
edge of the neuron and vomit their
neuromodulator out into the synapse and
then the neuromodulator in this case
dopamine will bind to receptors on the
postsynaptic side that means to another
neuron and then depending on how much
binds and depending on what else is
going on in that local neighborhood of
neuronal connections the neuron will
either increase its neural activity and
itself release neuromodulator and
neurotransmitter someplace else so sort
of a chain reaction or else it will
suppress its activity and the flow of
communication from one neuron to the
next will be stopped okay so MDMA
doesn't prevent the release of dopamine
at the synapse it does quite the
opposite it actually prevents the
sucking up of the dopamine that's been
released and that does not bind to The
receptors so basically what it does is
it blocks these things called dopamine
Transporters and the Transporters are
the things that suck back up the
dopamine that's been released that has
not bound to receptors so because it
blocks that sucking up process
there's more dopamine around in the
synapse to hang out and then bind to
receptors once some become available
okay the other thing that the
methamphetamine component of MDMA does
just like methamphetamine is that it
actually gets into what we call the
presynaptic neuron the neuron that
releases the dopamine and it interferes
with the repackaging of dopamine into
those vesicles now you might think oh it
interferes with the repackaging of
dopamine into vesicles and therefore
less will be released but actually what
happens is as a consequence of that
a bunch of dopamine builds up in the
presynaptic neuron so that when an
electrical impulse comes down that
neuron and dopamine is released a huge
amount of dopamine is released and this
is one of the characteristic properties
of methamphetamine end of MDMA which is
that it leads to enormous increases in
the amount of dopamine released and the
amount of dopamine that hangs around in
the synapse and therefore it increases
what we call dopaminergic Tone or
dopaminergic drive that's just a bunch
of different ways to describe increases
in dopamine okay so that's the main way
that MDMA and by extension
methamphetamine increase dopamine
however MDMA is not just methamphetamine
it's methylene dioxide methamphetamine
and it has another incredible property
which is that it doesn't just lead to
huge increases in dopamine it also leads
to huge increases in serotonin and
that's because there are other neurons
that release serotonin and they have
serotonin transporters which are
sometimes called certs s-e-r-t-s's
serotonin Transporters and they work
very much in the same way that dopamine
Transporters do right they basically
control the sucking backup of Serotonin
that's been released into the synapse
and that has not bound to serotonin
receptors on the other neurons yet and
in doing so allow more serotonin to hang
out and have its effects as those
receptors become available for serotonin
to bind to them the other thing MDMA
does is it also gets into the
presynaptic neuron to impact the
packaging of Serotonin into something
called the vesicle monoamine transporter
for serotonin and in doing so it leads
to a big buildup of serotonin in
presynaptic Terminals and then massive
increases in serotonin release okay so
what we've got with MDMA is a really
interesting compound unlike
methamphetamine or other amphetamines
such as adderall Vyvanse Etc that cause
increases in dopamine by blocking
reuptake and increasing release of
dopamine MDMA does that but it also does
the same thing for serotonin and here's
a really key point
the increases in serotonin that MDMA
creates are at least three times and
maybe as much as eight times greater
than the amount of dopamine released
that MDMA causes but when you put those
two things together what you basically
have is a drug that causes huge
increases in dopamine and even bigger
increases in serotonin
and remember earlier when I said that
MDMA is a purely synthetic compound as
far as we know it does not exist in any
plants or fungus or anything else in
nature well
this is a very unusual circumstance of
having big increases in dopamine and big
increases in serotonin caused by the
same compound and that combination of
big increases in dopamine and big
increases in serotonin are what lead to
these highly unusual and yet what seem
to be potentially clinically very
beneficial effects of having people feel
a lot of mood elevation and a lot of
stimulation from the stimulant
properties of the methamphetamine
component and so that's the dopamine
effect the dopaminergic tone goes way up
so it's a stimulant people feel really
alert they feel like talking a lot they
feel very excited they feel a lot of
positive motivation these are classic
effects of drugs that promote the
release of dopamine including
amphetamine cocaine Etc but ordinarily
that's not such a good thing because
what happens is there's then a crash in
the dopamine levels and then people feel
depressed they feel lethargic they they
don't feel good at all MDMA seems to
cause these increases in dopamine and
all the accompanying effects I just
described but by also causing big
increases in serotonin it activates
neural networks that are associated with
feeling more socially connected in fact
we'll talk about data in a little bit
where people have had their brains
imaged while under the influence of MDMA
and it's very clear that people who have
taken MDMA
look at faces that ordinarily they would
rate as fearful and rate them as less
fearful they see faces that are smiling
and they rate those smiling happy faces
as more positive than they would off the
drug the big increases in serotonin
create what we call a pro-social effect
and that combined with the dopaminergic
increase in mood and the stimulation
effect creates this thing that we call
an empathogen where and this is very
important the empathy isn't just for
other people it's also for oneself and
one's own experiences happening in the
moment as well as empathy for
experiences from the past which so you
can imagine could be very beneficial for
the treatment of PTSD Okay so
hopefully the way I describe the biology
of MDMA makes some sense if you didn't
get anything out of the description I
provided except the understanding that
MDMA is unusual in that it causes big
increases in dopamine and even bigger
increases in serotonin then you have
more in your knowledge base now about
MDMA than you need in order to
understand the rest of our discussion
before we go any further I do want to
separate MDMA out from some other
compounds which are referred to as
psychedelics and I recently did a
podcast episode all about psilocybin and
its therapeutic exploration and it's
chemical basis Etc you can find that
like all episodes at hubermanlab.com I
also did an episode with expert guest Dr
Robin Carhart Harris who's at University
of California San Francisco who's
pioneering a lot of the studies on the
clinical application of psilocybin
psilocybin and LSD
are mainly going to increase serotonin
activation in the brain in fact they
very closely resemble serotonin itself
and they activate What's called the
5ht2a or serotonin 5hd just stands for
serotonin the 5ht 2A receptor to create
very mystical type experiences they are
considered
classic psychedelics and are very
introspective
and as I described in those episodes are
being explored extensively now for the
treatment of major depression a
different compound that's being used for
the treatment of depression is ketamine
I will do an entire episode all about
ketamine ketamine
is actually a n methodaspartate receptor
blocker nmda receptor blocker that
shouldn't mean anything to most of you
but it is a dissociative anesthetic not
unlike PCP what used to be called angel
dust on the street ketamine is being
used as a treatment for depression it is
currently legal so unlike psilocybin and
LSD which are granted breakthrough
status for the study of depression but
are not yet legal they are still illegal
and of course as I mentioned earlier
MDMA has breakthrough status but is
still illegal ketamine is being used for
the treatment of depression and it does
so as its name suggests a dissociative
anesthetic by creating a sense of
dissociation from emotions okay now I
raise this distinction between
psilocybin and LSD which are mystical in
their effects
ketamine which is dissociative in its
effects with MDMA which is an empathogen
or sometimes called an anactogen but as
an empathogen or an enactogen it's
creating more affiliation it's
affiliative okay so it's a very distinct
compound and I think this is important
to understand because when we hear the
word psychedelic a lot of people tend to
lump together LSD psilocybin and MDMA if
you talk to researchers in these areas
they will tell you that MDMA really
isn't that much of a psychedelic it's an
empathogen with stimulant properties and
it also has the serotonergic component
that makes it an empathogen or an
actogen
so MDMA is very different than the other
psychedelics and my hunch is that over
the next few years we will stop talking
about MDMA as a psychedelic because it
does not tend to produce visual
hallucinations or auditory
hallucinations of the sort that classic
psychedelics do and in general it is
more of a mood impacting drug than it is
Mystical okay so we'll get into some of
the brain networks and which ones are
activated while under the influence of
MDMA but I do think it's very important
to segment out MDMA from the other
so-called classic psychedelics and also
segment it out from ketamine thanks to
some really terrific studies both in
animal models and in humans We Now
understand a lot of what makes MDMA
produce these incredibly unique effects
and when I say unique I mean unique from
drugs like psilocybin and LSD and
ketamine and from methamphetamine for
that matter and it's really the
combination of big increases in dopamine
and even bigger increases in serotonin
that create a situation where people
have more energy and yet
despite having more energy they don't
feel irritated
they feel a lot of pleasure they seem to
want to be in the state of having a lot
of energy this will become important as
we talk about anxiety and the anxiety
symptoms of PTSD it also because of the
big increases in serotonin produces a
sense of emotional warmth towards others
and towards oneself that's the
empathogen component and for reasons
that we still don't understand it seems
to increase trust and the increases in
trust turn out to be vital because as
you will you will also learn later when
we look at the clinical trials exploring
MDMA for the treatment of PTSD
the major effect of MDMA for the
treatment of PTSD is not to cure PTSD
but rather to make the therapy the talk
therapy for PTSD much more effective
this is a very important point in fact
so important I'm going to repeat it at
least three times during today's episode
MDMA taken on its own does not cure PTSD
MDMA can augment or boost the effects of
talk therapy for PTSD and it does that
through the engagement of specific
neural circuits but before we talk about
what those neural circuits are
I want to emphasize that the increases
in serotonin that MDMA produces
seem to act on different receptors
then the big increases in serotonin the
LSD and psilocybin produce so if you
listen to the episode that I did on
psilocybin we haven't done yet one on
LSD but the mechanisms are very similar
for psilocybin and LSD
whereby psilocybin and LSD
very closely mimic the molecule
serotonin itself but seem to have a more
selective activation of just the
so-called serotonin 2A receptor
abbreviated 5ht2a and that leads to
more interconnectedness between
different brain areas more consideration
of new possibilities about events from
the past present and future and also the
opening of so-called neuroplasticity of
rewiring of neural connections that
persist long after the psilocybin or LSD
effects have worn off
now MDMA can activate the serotonin 2A
receptor but it seems that it largely
activates the serotonin 1B receptor now
what does that mean activation of the
serotonin 1B receptor seems to be what
gives MDMA its very strong impact on the
neural circuits of the brain that relate
to trust and to social engagement not
just the willingness to engage socially
and to confide in a therapist or another
person but the intense desire to do so
and when I say intense desire that takes
us back to the dopamine system remember
dopamine even though
when increased in the brain can increase
our mood
it is largely responsible for increasing
our sense of motivation and desire for
something and to do something so the
increase in dopamine that's created by
MDMA seems to make people
what I call forward Center of mass you
know they want to do something they're
very motivated to do something and the
increases in serotonin acting on the
serotonin 1B receptor
seems to be what creates this desire to
bond or create trust or to have a
discussion of real things both things
that are positive but also to explore
things that are difficult and this I
realize is going to be a little bit of a
mind Bend for people to to understand
but one of the key things that
quality MDMA therapy consists of is not
just having a very good rapport and
communication with a therapist that's
guiding the PTSD treatment
but also Rapport and a willingness to
engage in conversations with oneself
yeah I think that most of us can relate
to the fact that we have experiences
some of which are hard some of which are
great and everything in between trauma
is I believe best defined by the words
that a former guest on this podcast
who's a world expert in trauma Paul
Conte explained as trauma is an event
that fundamentally changes the way that
our brain works
for the worse okay so not every bad
event of our past is trauma
but events that change the way that we
think our emotional tone or our behavior
in ways going forward that are not
adaptive for us They don't serve us well
either because they are highly
distracting or because
um they create anxiety or because they
disrupt sleep or any number of different
things that are maladaptive consequences
that's what really defines trauma and
when under the influence of MDMA because
of those parallel increases in dopamine
and serotonin people seem far more
willing to both trust the therapists
that they're talking about that trauma
with but also to trust their own ability
to quote unquote go internal and think
about the challenging thing or things
because oftentimes trauma can consist of
many events not just one event and the
thought patterns around that and the
context around that and therein to be
able to explore new possibilities to
essentially rewire their relationship to
that trauma so I promise that a little
bit later we'll talk about the the
direct application of MDMA for the
treatment of PTSD but now I'd like to
shift off of the chemical changes that
MDMA produces and some of the subjective
changes these increases in trust and
pleasure and energy and emotional warmth
to some of the brain circuits that are
activated and Modified by MDMA use and
then we will explore the toxicity issue
and then we will explore the clinical
studies of which I can promise you are
extremely exciting but until we
understand the neural circuit phenomena
and of course until we consider the
neurotoxicity issues I don't think those
clinical findings can be appreciated in
their full value but now I'd like to
talk about what MDMA really does in the
brain both in the short term while
someone is under the influence of the
drug and in the long term what sorts of
neuroplastic or rewiring changes does
MDMA produce and how can those be
beneficial or perhaps not beneficial I'd
like to take a quick break and
acknowledge one of our sponsors athletic
greens athletic greens now called ag-1
is a vitamin mineral probiotic drink
that covers all of your foundational
nutritional needs I've been taking
athletic green since 2012 so I'm
delighted that they're sponsoring the
podcast the reason I started taking
athletic greens and the reason I still
take athletic greens once are usually
twice a day is that it gets to be in the
probiotics that I need for gut health
our gut is very important it's populated
by gut microbiota that communicate with
the brain the immune system and
basically all the biological systems of
our body to strongly impact our
immediate and long-term health
and those probiotics and athletic greens
are optimal and vital for microbiotic
health in addition athletic greens
contains a number of adaptogens vitamins
and minerals that make sure that all of
my foundational nutritional needs are
met and it tastes great if you'd like to
try athletic greens you can go to
athleticgreens.com huberman and they'll
give you five free travel packs that
make it really easy to mix up athletic
greens while you're on the road in the
car on the plane Etc and they'll give
you a year's supply of vitamin d3k2
again that's athleticgreens.com huberman
to get the five free travel packs and
the year supply of vitamin D3 K2 so in
order to understand what MDMA does to
the human brain we need to take a step
back and really Define the sorts of
experiments that one could do so for
instance you could take a person who's
never ingested MDMA and put them into an
fmri machine which is functional
magnetic resonance imaging put them into
the fmri machine and just have them sit
there with their eyes closed what we
would call resting functional
connectivity
or arresting State functional
connectivity and simply look at how
interconnected certain brain areas are
which brain areas are active which brain
areas are less active at rest this is an
important thing to do not just to
provide a baseline for understanding
what the drug MDMA will subsequently do
but also because it addresses What's
called the default mode Network the
default mode Network or dmn is the
network that is active in our brains
when we aren't really attending to
anything specific outside us and we're
not trying to think about anything
specific or accomplish anything specific
it actually relates to our sense of
imagination and daydreaming it has a lot
to do with our self-referencing you know
what we're thinking about ourselves this
may come as no surprise but if you're
just sitting there on the bus or you
know around the dinner table and you're
not paying attention to what's going on
in large part your brain is in this
default mode Network and you're thinking
about yourself okay so we can get a
sense of what the default mode Network
activation is we can get a sense of
which brain areas are more or less
active simply by putting somebody into
an fmri machine
then of course you could give somebody
MDMA while they are in the fmri machine
and see how the activation of different
brain networks changes and then of
course you could analyze how the default
mode networks and other brain networks
change in the days and weeks and even
years after the drug has worn off
so-called neuroplasticity effects what
changed in a permanent or pervasive way
okay so that's sort of one basic
Paradigm for exploring the effects of
drugs like MDMA on the brain the other
way that you can explore the effects of
MDMA on the brain is to ask people in
the general population hey who out there
is taking MDMA how many times have you
taken it and come on into the laboratory
and we will image your brain and compare
people who have for instance taken MDMA
zero times to people who have taken MDMA
one time or five times or believe it or
not there's some studies sitting right
here in front of me on my desk of people
who have taken MDMA more than 200 times
and ask the same sorts of questions
which brain areas are more or less
active those Studies have been done as
well and of course one can do studies
where you give people different dosages
of MDMA as well as giving people MDMA
and then giving them specific stimuli
meaning not just asking them to sit
there in the fmri scanner with eyes
closed looking at the resting state
functional connectivity
but also how the brain responds to the
presentation of happy faces or sad faces
or images of oneself or even images that
recall memories of traumatic events and
so on so fortunately all of those sorts
of Studies have been done in humans and
there are also a large number of studies
in animal models exploring how the
social activity of laboratory mice
changes when they are under the effects
of MDMA or even studies believe it or
not on the effects of MDMA encephalopods
cephalopods include octopuses as well as
cuttlefish and other Aquatic animals
that are known for having complex
Behavior some people believe that the
cephalopods are extremely intelligent
you know the obsession with cephalopods
is something that really intrigues me I
actually used to have cuttlefish in my
laboratory we did not put them on MDMA
but there is a study that's been
published in the journal current biology
it's a cell Press Journal excellent
Journal this is from Google Dolan's
laboratory at Johns Hopkins school of
medicine showing that if you give
octopuses MDMA they like to spend more
time with other octopuses than they do
if they are not on MDMA and that might
sound like kind of a um kind of a
playful experiment just done uh in order
to entertain oneself and the octopuses
perhaps but actually in that study they
identified the serotonin transporter in
octopuses and show that it has a lot of
homology similarity to human serotonin
transporter receptors and so what that
really speaks to is the fact that the
pro-social effects of MDMA that are
observed in mice and in humans and in
octopuses all have a common basis which
is the activation of more serotonin
release in particular brain networks
okay so that interesting study on
octopuses aside I think what most of us
are interested in is how MDMA impacts
the brain and so I'm going to spell out
the three major ways in which MDMA
changes the activation of the brain in
the short and long term and here I'm
pooling across a number of different
studies but one of the key sets of
studies in this area comes from the what
I consider very beautiful work of
Harriet DeWitt Harriet DeWitt runs the
human behavioral pharmacology lab in the
department of Psychiatry and behavioral
neuroscience at the University of
Chicago in her laboratory has a long
history of giving people certain drugs
in very specific dosages and then
measuring their effects on the brain
using different types of Imaging
including fmri
and one particular study that I'll
highlight is entitled effects of MDMA on
sociability and neural responses to
social threat and social reward so what
the study looked at is how MDMA impacts
people's perceptions of others emotional
Expressions on their face what they
found is that when people are on MDMA
their response to threatening faces or
other threatening stimuli is reduced and
it's reduced in a very specific way
which is reductions in activity of the
amygdala the amygdala is a structure
that some of you may be familiar with it
is known to be involved in the threat
detection systems or networks of the
brain it is sometimes called the fear
area of the brain although I want to
caution people against assigning any one
particular subjective experience to any
one particular brain area the amygdala
is actually a complex it's actually
called the amygdaloid complex and has a
lot of different sub areas and it's
involved in a lot of things besides fear
and threat detection nonetheless when
people are under the influence of MDMA
and you show them a face that is
grimacing or would otherwise be rated as
quite threatening they tend to rate it
as less threatening in addition they
tend to respond to happy faces or even
slightly happy faces as more
kind or more generous or happier than
they would when they are not on MDMA
again the faces that are being shown are
not of people on MDMA that would be an
interesting experiment but that's not
what they did here what's Happening Here
is people are being given MDMA and then
they are raiding in a subjective way the
friendliness or the level of threat that
they detect in these facial expressions
and of course they have extremes of
friendly and threatening but then they
also grade them right they titrate them
so that they also have mildly
threatening and mildly happy faces Etc
so everything from a grin to a smirk to
a giant smile everything from a from a
sort of a you know somebody looking a
little bit of scans at somebody to
really you know wide-eyed and looking
angry like they're you know gonna attack
you and things of that sort so what's
discovered in the study is that MDMA has
a bi-directional effect on our
perception of others emotions making
people more likely to rate something as
positive if it's initially positive or
even a little bit positive and less
likely to rate a threatening face as
more threatening now one thing I have
not mentioned thus far are the dosages
of MDMA used in this and in other
studies unfortunately despite the
studies that we're going to talk about
using a lot of different types of people
different ages different Sexes so male
and female located in different parts of
the world even some with PTSD some not
with PTSD Etc there's been fairly tight
dosage control of MDMA in these studies
it's not perfectly matched from study to
study but it's pretty darn close which
makes interpreting results across
studies a lot easier for me and
therefore for you
the typical dosages of MDMA used in
these neuroimaging studies and in the
clinical studies of PTSD that we're
going to talk about later
range anywhere from 0.75 milligrams per
kilogram of body weight to 1.5
milligrams per kilogram of body weight
so for somebody like me I weigh 220
pounds that's 100 milligrams
1.5 milligrams per kilogram of body
weight would therefore be 150 milligrams
in a single dose okay
a dosage of one milligram per kilogram
of body weight would mean 100 milligrams
for my 100 kilograms okay somebody
lighter than 100 kilograms would
obviously take less MDMA in one of these
studies but in general the range of MDMA
that's been explored is 0.75 to 1.5
milligrams per kilogram of body weight
the exception being in the clinical
studies that we'll talk about a little
bit later there's a tendency to explore
both an initial dose of 1.5 milligrams
per kilogram of body weight so again for
a hundred kilogram person that would be
150 milligrams or so and then a
so-called booster of half that amount
about 90 minutes to two and a half hours
into the session so another 75
milligrams later and I should point out
that there is not always the inclusion
of the so-called booster and in some
cases lower doses of MDMA such as the
0.75 milligrams per kilogram dosages are
used why am I getting so into the
details of dosages well
if we are going to talk about toxicity
of MDMA we absolutely have to talk about
dosages because
like any drug the toxicity of MDMA does
scale with the dosage that's applied not
just the frequency of MDMA use
we hear a lot about that you know
someone has taken MDMA one time or four
times or 200 times we hear about
frequency of use but rarely do we hear
about the specific dosages that are
taken in any one particular session so
when we talk about the subjective
effects or the brain networks that are
activated when people take MDMA in
general we're talking about
dosages somewhere between 0.75
milligrams per kilogram of body weight
and 1.5 milligrams per kilogram of body
weight although typically you're going
to see studies both clinical and more
research explorative using anywhere from
1 to 1.5 milligrams of MDMA per kilogram
of body weight so that's important to
highlight I told you about the
subjective effects of MDMA engaging the
responses of people's faces but I didn't
tell you about the brain areas that are
responsible except for the reduction in
amygdala activity now one of the key
features of PTSD seems to be that there
is a heightened connectivity between the
amygdala and a brain area called the
insula the insula is a brain area that's
very important for something that's
called interoception
interoception is one's perception of our
feelings both pure Sensations but also
our emotional states and our feelings of
well-being or lack of well-being for
everything from our skin inward okay so
that's interoception you actually can
intercept now even though you're always
intercepting a little bit you can
intercept now to a great degree if you
were to for instance close your eyes or
simply focus on the contact points
between your body and any surface that
you happen to be contacting so maybe the
backs of your legs against a chair or
your feet against the floor or the
bottoms of your shoes or sandals your
nervous system is constantly sensing
those contact points but normally
they're not under your conscious
awareness unless you direct Your
interceptive Capacity to them which is
just fancy nerd speak for saying you
normally don't notice what's going on
from your skin inward unless you focus
on it that focus is interception
it can be about the fullness of your gut
it can be about how happy or sad you are
it can be about how tired or alert you
happen to feel but that's interception
and it is distinctly different from
exteriorception which is your ability
and tendency to focus on things beyond
the confines of your skin so this could
be visual attention auditory attention
it could be paying attention to events
like birds flying by whether or not your
Uber is showing up these kinds of things
and we are always in a balance a
push-pull of interoception and extra
reception the insula is a brain area
that is absolutely critical for
interception so much so that it has a
map of the complete body surface
including our internal organs
in other words if you put somebody into
an fmri machine or you were to record
from the insula with electrodes as has
been done in humans many times now
during the course of neurosurgery for
other purposes what you would find is
that if you stimulate neurons in one end
of the insula the person will say oh you
know I I feel something going on in my
gut and on my left side and then as you
were to March that stimulation across
the insula you would find that they
would now be paying attention to their
legs or just to one leg or to their
whole body or to the sensations in their
face or their head so there's a
systematic map of interoception in the
insula and there are direct connections
between the amygdala and the insula and
the amygdala despite getting this
reputation as just being a fear Center
or a threat detection Center is actually
part of a much larger set of networks
that include inputs from the hippocampus
an area of the brain that's involved in
memory formation and Storage
and what is observed is that people who
have PTSD tend to have greater or rather
stronger connections between the
amygdala and the insula than is normally
observed in people who do not have PTSD
okay so there seems to be heightened
input from the threat detection centers
of the brain to this area of the brain
the insula that is responsible for our
sense of interception which provides a
logical explanation for why people with
PTSD often will feel the memory or sense
the discomfort or just feel agitation or
even other types of bodily Sensations
like back pain or just perhaps just a
sense within their body that's more
generalized it doesn't even have to be
pain doesn't even have to be negative
but that's associated with the negative
memory of some traumatic event or series
of events okay so this is a really
interesting brain Network that I should
mention exists in everybody but that in
people with PTSD seems to have
heightened connectivity and those brain
networks can be revealed by putting
people with PTSD into functional Imaging
machines
getting them to recall a traumatic event
or even looking at the resting state of
connectivity between the amygdala and
the insula so those experiments have
been done and what's also been done is
to give people 1.5 milligrams per
kilogram of MDMA and to look at the
connectivity between the amygdala and
the insula and between the hippocampus
the amygdala and the insula and so
what's observed over time in people that
have been given MDMA and this is a very
important
and and have done therapy for PTSD both
before during and after
the drug there's a weakening of
connections between the amygdala and the
insula and that scales very directly
with the relief of symptoms from PTSD so
this is really exciting because it's one
thing to see a brain Network get
activated or inactivated or you say okay
in one person a certain connection
between threat centers and the
interceptive centers of the brain was
let's say arbitrary units let's say it
was level eight out of ten for that
person right these things are normalized
for a particular person and then after
taking MDMA and doing PTSD therapy it
was five out of ten or four out of ten
that's a good experiment but what's far
more powerful is to observe that in that
patient or that person and then to see a
change that's perhaps less dramatic so a
shift from 8 out of 10 to 7 out of ten
in another person and to see less shift
in brain connectivity in the same
network and then perhaps in the person
that went from full-blown PT PSD to full
remission of PTSD something that believe
it or not has been observed in single
sessions with MDMA
if that person demonstrates an even
greater reduction in the connections
between the amygdala and the incilla
well then that gives even more
confidence that this connection between
the amygdala and the insula is actually
perhaps causally related to the
reduction in symptoms of PTSD or even if
it's just correlated with reduction in
symptoms of PTSD the fact that the
degree of reduction of connection of
this circuit scales with the reduction
in clinically relevant symptoms that's a
very powerful finding because it moves
things away from Pure correlation
although this brain area is active or
less active over time and you know this
person has more or fewer symptoms of
PTSD to something that starts to look
like a mechanistic and logical framework
for understanding
PTSD as well as the effects of MDMA and
for understanding how changes in the
brain underlie relief from PTSD okay so
again even if you just could grasp the
idea that you have a brain area the
amygdala that's involved in threat
detection and it provides inputs to
another brain area called the insula
which is involved in this thing called
interoception and that reductions in
those connections between the amygdala
and the insula scale with or correlate
with reductions in PTSD symptoms as a
consequence of people taking MDMA so if
you have that under your mental belt I
promise you you understand far more
about how MDMA impacts the brain in the
short and long term the 99.9 percent of
people out there
however it's also important you
understand a few other things that MDMA
does to the brain as well as what it
doesn't do to the brain first of all
classic psychedelics like psilocybin and
LSD as I mentioned earlier are known to
create more lateral connectivity between
different areas of the so-called
neocortex and these are long-lasting
changes that are thought to underlie
both some of the relief from major
depression but also some of the enhanced
creativity and some of the other things
that have been observed with psilocybin
treatment and again if you're interested
in psilocybin treatments and psilocybin
itself please check out the episode that
I did on psilocybin and the guest
episode with Dr Robin Carhartt Harris
those episodes like all other episodes
of The huberman Lab podcast can be found
at hubermanlab.com it's a fully
searchable site so you can put keywords
into the search function it will take
you to specific time stamps every
episode is time stamps you can navigate
to topics of particular interest to you
feel free to go there and listen to
those episodes about psilocybin MDMA by
contrast does not seem to produce long
lasting increases in lateral
connectivity between those same brain
networks probably because it impacts a
different serotonin receptors it does
however seem to change resting state
functional connectivity Within These
limbic structures like the amygdala and
related structures that are associated
with threat detection now this is
interesting and it actually was
highlighted very nicely in a study I'll
provide a link to in our show note
caption which actually has Dr Robin
Carter Harris as the first author so not
only has he done incredible work on
psilocybin and LSD and DMT in Ayahuasca
in his laboratory but also on MDMA and
the particular study I have in mind here
showed that people who take MDMA
at more or less the dosage that we
talked about earlier
report Mark increases in positive mood
as well as decreased blood flow to the
amygdala and hippocampus so again these
threat detection centers of the brain
and brain areas associated with
memory and those changes are seen both
while under the influence of MDMA and
afterwards when the brain is simply at
rest so it really does appear that MDMA
creates neuroplasticity that changes the
overall level of activation of these
threat detection networks and their
connections to memory systems in a way
that's pervasive over time and that
doesn't require any particular probe
with a negative
stimulus I'll translate to English what
that means is that during the MDMA
session
people report feeling less threatened
more pro-social towards others more
empathic towards others and themselves
and then after the session they have
less of a threat response to memories
that before the session were more
troubling and those changes in the brain
do seem to be pervasive so there are
both short-term and long-term effects of
MDMA all of which point in the direction
of lowered levels of threat detection
heightened levels of positivity
pro-social components of the brain more
active threat detection centers of the
brain less active now earlier we talked
about MDMA as a drug that potently
increases dopamine and even more
potently increases serotonin largely
acting through this serotonin 1B
receptor now without getting into too
many more details before moving on to
issues of toxicity around MDMA I do want
to touch on what I think is perhaps the
finest of the animal model studies of
MDMA that explored which brain networks
and
which chemical that is serotonin or
dopamine is responsible for say the
motivational components of MDMA versus
the pro-social effects of MDMA and then
it also raises a really important point
which I haven't mentioned yet in this
episode which is the role of oxytocin
something that many of you have perhaps
heard of
the paper that I'm going to describe is
from the laboratory of Dr Robert malenka
he's a colleague of mine at Stanford
University School of Medicine Psychiatry
and Behavioral Sciences
he is both a Pioneer and luminary in the
field of neuroplasticity of how the
brain wires and forms memories and can
change itself over time in response to
experience as well as the study of drugs
of abuse as well as the study of drugs
like MDMA and now additional compounds
that can provide therapeutic support in
certain conditions the study which I
will provide a link to in the show note
caption is entitled distinct neural
mechanisms for the pro-social and
rewarding properties of MDMA and I'm
just going to summarize the major
results of this study it's a study that
was done on mice and I realized that a
lot of people will hear that and think
ah what relevance does that have to
humans but when thinking about the
effects of dopamine and serotonin in the
types of circuits that we've been
talking about thus far
these circuits that are subcortical as
we refer to them so these are limbic
circuits these are hypothalamic circuits
these are what are called mesolymbic
circuits these are all names for
circuits that are highly conserved
between mice and humans
and so results in mice really do
translate quite well to results in
humans at least insofar as the effects
of MDMA and which neurochemicals are
involved is concerned so what they found
in the study using a huge array of
beautiful techniques such as
inactivation of specific brain areas
activation of specific brain areas drug
antagonists to prevent oxytocin function
or drug antagonist to prevent specific
receptors involved in the serotonin
pathway lots and lots of tools in their
toolkit what they found is that MDMA
causing the release of dopamine
is what really establishes the rewarding
effects of an experience this isn't
really a surprise
we've known that MDMA just like cocaine
or Methamphetamine or Adderall for that
matter or Vyvanse for that matter
creates big increases in dopamine that
tend to couple an experience with a
sense of reward
and lead to changes in the neural
circuitry that make the animal or human
more likely to seek out that same
experience again okay these are the
rewarding or sometimes called
reinforcing properties of dopamine that
take place in the so-called mesolimbic
reward pathway if you want to learn
about mesolimic reward Pathways and
dopamine and how they control everything
from your level of motivation to your
tendency to procrastinate or overcome
procrastination I've done two episodes
about dopamine you can simply go to
hubermanlab.com put dopamine into the
search function and you'll find at least
two episodes on that topic and you'll
also find a number of different tools
related to how one can better regulate
their own patterns of dopamine release
for sake of motivation Etc
so MDMA is increasing dopamine to
increase reward to a particular
experience what's the experience well
this paper beautifully parses
the fact that it is serotonin release
within a structure called the nucleus
accumbens which is part of the reward
pathway which is rewarding the
experience of social interaction now
they do this by putting mice in arenas
where they have the option of either
spending time with other mice or not
spending time with other mice and
blocking the activation of certain brain
areas and again using drug antagonists
Etc and what they find is that it really
is the activation of the serotonin 1B
receptor
in the nucleus of Commons by MDMA that
leads to this pro-social effect of MDMA
so that's really nice to know because
there's always been this conundrum of
okay psilocybin and LSD are basically
like serotonin they activate the
serotonin 2A receptor MDMA has this huge
serotonergic component tons of Serotonin
released when one takes MDMA but very
different effects in the short and long
term
very different subjective effects very
different patterns of change activity in
the brain in the short and long term
well that's because MDMA is activating
the serotonin-1b receptor not the
serotonin 2A receptor and it's doing so
in a completely different set of brain
networks as is LSD and psilocybin so
what happens when an animal or a person
takes MDMA is that social connection is
strongly rewarded and reinforced making
social connection more likely after the
drug wears off
now that's one component of social
connection but in addition
people who take MDMA in the clinical
therapeutic setting for the treatment of
PTSD often report feeling more empathy
and compassion for themselves during the
session but also for long periods of
time maybe even indefinitely after the
session
so it really seems that the addition of
this huge release of Serotonin by MDMA
on top of the release of dopamine sets
in motion two parallel circuits one for
rewarding something anything that's the
dopamine component and then fortunately
because the increase in serotonin caused
by MDMA
increases empathy and sociability for
and with others but also for oneself
the motivation that's reinforced that's
wired into the brain seems to be a
motivation to perceive others as more
kind but also to be kinder to oneself
now I realize that for some of you who
are listening to this you're probably
saying well of course right you know
serotonin is pro-social and dopamine is
motivation so you put the two together
and people become more motivated to be
social and kinder to themselves ah but
it didn't necessarily have to be that
way right it is very hard to go from a
statement like drug a produces effects b
c and d to neurochemicals b c and d
cause motivation and sociability and
therefore when you take that drug you're
going to get all of that stuff in fact
we have to go back to our understanding
the MDMA despite causing a big increase
in serotonin also causes huge increases
in dopamine and it does so with this
molecule that is methamphetamine now
methamphetamine is not known to be a
pro-social drug in fact a study I just
referred to as well as some human
Studies have explored how the
application of methamphetamine so not
MDMA but pure methamphetamine impacts
social interactions and what it does to
social interactions it's very profound
it dramatically reduces one's tendency
to engage in social interaction so this
really speaks to the poly pharmacology
as it's called of MDMA the fact that
serotonin and dopamine are released
together has distinctly different
effects than if just dopamine or just
serotonin is increased so much so that
it's worth taking a step back and
talking about another class of drugs
which dramatically increases serotonin
which are the ssris The Selective
serotonin reuptake Inhibitors ssris such
as fluoxetine Prozac as well as Zoloft
and of course there are many other
accessories out there citalopram Etc
they block the reuptake of Serotonin and
thereby lead to net increases in the
amount of Serotonin and yet those drugs
are not known to create
even close to the same sorts of effects
as MDMA
in fact there have been human and animal
studies showing that if you give
somebody an SSRI prior to them taking
MDMA you actually block the pro-social
and empathogenic effects of MDMA now you
might say why in the world would that be
aren't these drugs just increasing
serotonin and the increase in serotonin
is pro-social ETC ah well that speaks to
the complexity of all this poly
pharmacology and the fact that it's
really the activation of Serotonin at
particular receptors in this case the
serotonin 1B receptor in particular
brain areas in this case the nucleus
accumbens a brain area associated with
motivation and reward
that largely explains the effects of
MDMA in making people and animals and
octopuses included for that matter more
pro-social and more empathic towards
themselves
it's not just an issue of raising the
levels of one neurochemical it's really
about raising levels of a particular
neurochemical acting in particular
receptors in particular brain areas and
in the case of MDMA the fact that
there's also dopamine increased in those
very same brain areas right I don't
think I mentioned this before but the
nucleus accumbens is part of that
mesolimbic reward pathway that is
essentially establishing a reward for
whatever is happening at the moment
so the way to conceptualize MDMA and its
effects on the brain both subjectively
and mechanistically is that it's an
empathogen for which empathy and social
connection is very strongly reinforced
while under the influence of the drug
and in a way so intense and Powerful
that those neural networks get stronger
and persist in being more active for
long periods of time after the drug has
worn off I'd like to just take a brief
break and thank one of our sponsors
which is element element is an
electrolyte drink that has everything
you need and nothing you don't that
means plenty of salt sodium magnesium
and potassium the so-called electrolytes
and no sugar now salt magnesium and
potassium are critical to the function
of all the cells in your body in
particular to the function of your nerve
cells also called neurons and we now
know that even slight reductions in
electrolyte concentrations or
dehydration of the body can lead to
deficits and cognitive and physical
performance element contains a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of 1000
milligrams that's one gram of sodium 200
milligrams of potassium and 60
milligrams of magnesium I typically
drink element first thing in the morning
when I wake up in order to hydrate my
body and make sure I have enough
electrolytes and while I do any kind of
physical training and after physical
training as well especially if I've been
sweating a lot and certainly I drink
element in my water when I'm in the
sauna and after going in the sauna
because that causes quite a lot of sweat
setting if you'd like to try element you
can go to drink element that's lmnt.com
huberman to claim a free element sample
pack with your purchase again that's
drink element lmnt.com huberman now one
of the things that's been explored in
both the animal literature and the human
literature is that MDMA doesn't just
increase dopamine and doesn't just
increase serotonin but it also
profoundly increases levels of oxytocin
release in the brain now oxytocin is
considered what's called a neuro hormone
because it acts as both a
neurotransmitter or I guess if we were
going to be really specific we'd say a
neuromodulator because it tends to
modulate the activity of a bunch of
other circuits and a hormone how can we
say it's a hormone or a modulator or
transmitter well hormonal effects tend
to be effects that act not just locally
but on many sites within the brain and
body as well and oxytocin is known to do
that as well as to work locally so
that's why we call a neuro hormone it
activates neurons and is associated with
neural networks related to pair bonding
both between parent and child both
mother and child and father and child or
caretaker and child not just biological
parent
as well as bonding between friends
bonding between lovers and it's thought
to actually be involved in the process
that is the painful process of breaking
of bonds when people are no longer
available to us as caretakers or as
partners either by way of breakup death
departure Etc in fact there are even
data suggesting that humans can have
strong oxytocin responses to their pets
in particular dogs and their dogs can
have strong oxytocin
patterns of release in response to their
owners I think for any dog lovers or dog
owners certainly includes me I'm raising
my hand
that comes as no surprise anyone that's
ever had to put down a dog or has lost a
dog and hear no disrespect to the cat
owners but I'm just referring to the
studies that have been done on humans
and dogs
you can certainly relate to the
incredible pain of that loss oxytocin is
thought to be involved in bonding
between people and other creatures as
well as the breaking of those bonds
MDMA is known to powerfully increase
oxytocin release in fact there's a
really nice study on this done in humans
this is a study I'll provide a link to
in the show note captions entitled
plasma oxytocin concentrations following
MDMA or intranasal oxytocin in humans
nowadays oxytocin is available by nasal
inhaler
to be honest I don't know the legality
around it I don't know if it's a gray
Market or but what I'm about to tell you
will basically discourage you from
wanting to take it because what they
found in the study was
people given either 0.75 or 1.5
milligrams per kilogram of body weight
of MDMA experienced increases in
oxytocin however it was only the group
that took 1.5 milligrams per kilogram of
body weight of MDMA that experienced the
really big significant changes in
oxytocin and when I say really big
really highly statistically significant
what they observed is that in the
placebo group
because of course they include a placebo
group the amount of circulating oxytocin
was 18.6 picograms per milliliter which
to you probably means nothing and to me
also sort of means nothing because those
units of oxytocin can't be directly
related to any kind of direct experience
of feeling bonded or not bonded that's
just a number but nonetheless it
provides a baseline to compare to the
average levels of oxytocin in the
bloodstream of people that were given
1.5 milligrams per kilogram of MDMA
which is 83.7 picograms per milliliter
that equates to nearly a five-fold
increase in the amount of circulating
oxytocin when people are under the
influence of MDMA
now this study had a bunch of different
conditions not just MDMA of different
doses not just placebo
they also had people take oxytocin by
nasal spray which we know can change
levels of circulating oxytocin and
indeed when measured in the study it did
change levels of circulating oxytocin
and the end point in the study was to
have people
give subjective ratings of their
feelings of
connectedness to one another as well as
rate and here I'm just drawing directly
from the paper of how much they like the
feeling how much they felt high they
measure their heart rate their systolic
pressure their diastolic blood pressure
Etc and they looked at how
social people felt they looked at how
insightful people felt and the key
takeaway from the study for sake of our
discussion here today is that it does
not again it does not appear that the
increases in oxytocin produced by taking
MDMA
are the source of the pro-social effects
of MDMA
and that's also what was found in the
animal studies of MDMA where in those
studies
mice were given MDMA at comparable doses
the doses were a little bit higher than
used in the human studies but at
comparable doses
big increases in oxytocin were observed
increases in sociability
of those mice were observed just as they
are in humans that take MDMA but in
those mice they were also given a drug
to block the oxytocin receptor and lo
and behold no changes in sociability
were observed
in humans that take oxytocin by nasal
spray
you can see big increases in oxytocin
that's not surprising gets across the
blood-brain barrier oxytocin goes up
and levels of sociability do not
increase
so what this points to is a situation
where MDMA is increasing dopamine to
increase motivation and to reward
something what gets rewarded well what
gets rewarded is the serotonin
activation of particular brain networks
associated with sociability and the
dramatic increases in oxytocin that are
very very real when people take MDMA do
not appear to underlie any of the known
short or long-term subjective effects of
MDMA now a conclusion like that needs to
have a caveat and the caveat is that as
far as we know the big increases in
oxytocin that are produced by MDMA
aren't doing anything for the sorts of
effects that we've been talking about
here sociability empathy Etc but there
could be other effects of oxytocin that
we're just not aware of that said the
data from both animal models and in
humans really point to the fact that the
increases in oxytocin that are produced
by MDMA are not directly related to any
of the short and long-term effects of
MDMA that we are most familiar with
namely motivation sociability increase
empathy or the long-standing changes in
neural circuitry that underlie for
instance reduce threat detection or
reduce connectivity between threats
detection centers of the brain and in
terreception so is the big increase in
oxytocin produced by MDMA completely
irrelevant in the context of this
discussion we don't know it appears that
it's not very relevant is oxytocin a
meaningless molecule right after all
they gave these people nasal infusions
of oxytocin oxytocin and went way up
they didn't observe anything very
interesting or significant in the
context of sociability but we do know
that oxytocin can play a powerful role
in pair bonding and in human human
animal bonding of various kinds from
other experiments that have been done so
I don't want to diminish the incredible
power that oxytocin has in our brains
and bodies but it doesn't appear that
the MDMA induced increases in oxytocin
which are enormous have much to do with
anything related to the value of MDMA as
a treatment for PTSD or for its
subjective effects on empathy
sociability or any of those other
factors either now perhaps the one
caveat to that is that hair Harriet
Dewitt's laboratory which I referred to
earlier has looked at how variations in
oxytocin receptor genes vary between
people so it turns out that some people
have an allele a basically a version of
the oxytocin receptor that is different
from other people that makes oxytocin
work differently and actually less
effectively in activating certain brain
networks and it does appear that when
those people take MDMA they actually it
experience less of a pro-social effect
of the drug now that spits in the face
of everything I just said about oxytocin
not being involved in the effects of
MDMA on pro-sociability and empathy
I think the bulk of the data really
points to the fact that it's the
serotonin increases combined with the
dopamine increases caused by MDMA that
lead to most of the understood effects
and that oxytocin if it's playing a role
is going to play a more minor role let's
talk about the safety and potential
neurotoxicity of MDMA and here I really
want to highlight that our discussion
today is couched in a discussion about
the application of pure MDMA to animals
or humans in the context of laboratory
or clinical studies this is really
important to point out because I would
be remiss if I didn't note that
there is a lot of recreational use of
MDMA in fact it was the recreational use
of MDMA in the 1980s but really that
took off even exploded in the 1990s with
so-called Rave culture that created the
massive attention on illegality of MDMA
and put the drug enforcement agencies
onto MDMA as a drug that they wanted to
and indeed do restrict in fact just
today in anticipation of this episode I
put MDMA into the search function on
Google and clicked news and there were
at least two reports of major MDMA
seizures and bus so again I want to
highlight the fact that MDMA is still
illegal to possess or sell and certainly
to traffic I also want to highlight the
fact that nowadays all recreational
drugs but certainly MDMA included
are often in fact very often
contaminated with fentanyl and while
fentanyl has certain clinical uses
fentanyl is highly deadly the current
estimates are as much as 60 percent
maybe even 80 percent of drugs that are
sold on the gray Market are being
repackaged or reformulated with fentanyl
and there have been a lot of fentanyl
related deaths both in kids and adults
so the sourcing of MDMA is extremely
important and the safety issues simply
cannot be overlooked
and I say that not to protect me I say
that to protect you right the last thing
any of us want is for someone to take a
compound thinking it's one compound and
it contains another compound and I'm
getting hurt or even dying and that is
happening a lot a lot and it is
certainly happening a lot for people
that think that they're buying MDMA
the use of MDMA in the laboratory or in
the clinical setting
with pure MDMA has also been explored
for the potential neurotoxicity of MDMA
so how would methamphetamine and MDMA be
neurotoxic well that's because they
increase dopamine in the case of
methamphetamine and dopamine and
serotonin in the case of MDMA and they
do so to a very high degree
the big increases in dopamine and
serotonin but in particular the big
increases in dopamine tend to promote
electrical activity of other neurons
remember these are after all
neuromodulators they modulate up or down
the activity of other neurons and
dopamine tends to modulate the activity
of other neurons up
so dopamine itself is not neurotoxic but
when a lot of dopamine is released it is
neurotoxic and it's well known that even
a single dose of methamphetamine can be
neurotoxic not just for dopamine neurons
but for other types of neurons as well
including serotonergic neurons
put differently we know that the brains
of people that take methamphetamine
degenerate to a smaller or to a large
degree depending on how often they take
the drug how potent the drug is and
whether or not they combine it with
other drugs and yes
if you heard that combining caffeine
with amphetamines can increase the
neurotoxicity of amphetamines such as
methamphetamine that is true if you've
heard that taking caffeine within the
hours or same day as MDMA can increase
the toxicity of MDMA that does appear to
be true based on animal studies now
there are not a lot of studies looking
at the toxicity of MDMA in humans but
there are a few
there are also studies looking at the
toxicity of MDMA in animal models
including non-human primate models now
this is a very complex literature a lot
of results not all over the place but
they're scattered in a number of ways
first of all some of the animal Studies
have used dosages of MDMA as high as two
milligrams per kilogram of body weight
as high as three milligrams per kilogram
of body weight and even in upwards of
that
but even for the animal studies that
used a range of dosages from 0.75 to 1.5
milligrams per kilogram of body weight
there is some evidence that in
laboratory Miser rats there can be some
loss of serotonergic tone in the brains
of animals that have been administered
MDMA now notice I said serotonergic tone
I didn't say serotonin neurons
because of the way that MDMA Works in
encouraging or promoting big releases in
dopamine big releases in serotonin it's
not surprising that if the animals that
were given MDMA are subsequently
sacrificed say later that day or the
next day or maybe even a week or two
weeks later and those brains are stained
for proteins that are related to the
synthesis or release of Serotonin it's
not surprising that there would be
reductions in those sorts of proteins
right after all a lot of dopamine and
serotonin is released and it can be
depleted but I should point out
depletion of a neuromodulator in the
short term is not the same thing as
depletion of that neuromodulator in the
long term nor is it the same as loss of
the neurons that release dopamine and
serotonin itself
so there are data pointing to the fact
that repeated administration of MDMA
at dosages that are very much within
lines with what we're talking about
today 1.5 milligrams per kilogram of
body weight
can lower total amounts of Serotonin or
other proteins in the serotonin
synthesis pathway or dopamine or
proteins that are in the dopamine
synthesis pathway in specific areas of
the brain related to reinforcement
related to mood related to motivation
Etc however
the primate studies or I should say the
non-human primate studies which are the
sorts of animal studies that most
closely mimic what one expects to see in
the human brain because after all mice
and the effects of these drugs and mice
do translate to humans but it's thought
that non-human primates provide a model
that's far more similar to humans
there the data start to get kind of
complicated in a way that suggests that
MDMA might not be as neurotoxic as is
thought based on the rodent studies and
this gets into a whole history of back
and forth between different Laboratories
and governing bodies who are trying to
keep MDMA legal as well as people such
as the Sasha Shoguns of the world and
people in the therapy community that are
excited about the potential for MDMA
becoming legal for the treatment of PTSD
and it really centers around one or two
studies
both of which were published in very
high profile journals and the one that
I'll highlight because the results are
now very clear and conclusive is a study
that was published back in 2002 which
was entitled severe dopaminergic
neurotoxicity in primates after a common
recreational dose regimen of MDMA
or ecstasy
this paper was published in the journal
science which is one of the three Apex
journals for publishing scientific
research so there's science nature and
cell those are the top top journals most
stringent journals to get scientific
manuscripts into
the paper received a lot of attention
because as you can imagine based on the
title it suggested that even
recreational doses of ecstasy even if
it's pure ecstasy and it doesn't have
contamination from additional
methamphetamine or other things in it is
neurotoxic to serotonergic and or
dopaminergic neurons this is largely
where MDMA got the reputation for quote
unquote putting holes in your brain
however
this study came under a lot of scrutiny
for a couple of reasons first of all and
I'm certainly not saying this but it was
argued that the authors of the study
were perhaps trying to prevent the
legalization of MDMA for the treatment
of PTSD as far as I know there's no
direct evidence that that statement is
true but you will actually find that in
some of the scientific journals in fact
I was able to find a an editorial that
was published in the biomedical journal
in 2003 which argued
somehow that Dr riccarte was accused of
quote rushing his results into print
because of legislation designed to curb
ecstasy use before U.S Congress so you
know there were some uh connotations or
I'd rather there were some strong
suggestions that there was a political
backing to trying to get this study done
quickly and into print and so forth I
don't think that ever really got
resolved what did get resolved however
is that
the very study in question was retracted
okay so the authors themselves published
a letter of retraction
that unfortunately is not as well
recognized as the paper that stimulated
this idea that MDMA is neurotoxic in
primates and keep in mind that we are
human primates non-human primates being
the closest model to human primates that
we are aware of but to make a long story
short
there were some issues of labeling of
MDMA versus other drugs in the
laboratory there were some issues of
mislabeling all of which were eventually
acknowledged by the authors of the study
and they concluded in fact they verified
based on some very detailed analysis
that what these monkeys were injected
with was not actually MDMA but rather
was methamphetamine itself
so what's not often acknowledged is the
retraction of the paper on neurotoxicity
and unfortunately the neurotoxicity
issue is often what's mentioned now keep
in mind there are studies in rodents
showing neurotoxicity of MDMA perhaps
even at recreational doses but to date
at least to my knowledge
there don't seem to be any data in
either non-human primates or in humans
showing toxicity of MDMA at clinically
relevant doses provided it is pure MDMA
I want to be very clear I'm not saying
that if you can get pure MDMA that you
should take it or that it won't be
neurotoxic certainly we can expect that
because of the huge known variation in
dopamine receptors in serotonin
receptors and of course because of the
known interactions between MDMA and
other compounds in particular caffeine
but also drugs such as cocaine or other
stimulants
that some people might experience more
toxicity to a given dose of MDMA
compared to somebody else and there's
really no way to detect that
susceptibility to neurotoxicity now what
we do know is that there are people in
the general population that have taken a
lot of MDMA anywhere from 1 to 200 or
sometimes even in excess of 400 doses of
MDMA and they're now our studies that
have explored
the neurotoxicity and perhaps even more
importantly the neurocognitive and
behavioral effects of
taking MDMA either zero times one time
five times forty times 200 times etc etc
and one of the what I would consider
Landmark studies in this area is a study
entitled residual neurocognitive
features of long-term ecstasy users with
minimal exposure to other drugs and
those words with minimal exposure to
other drugs is really key in the context
of this conversation
because as I mentioned before
interactions between drugs what's called
polypharmacology can create
neurotoxicity it's unclear if MDMA is
neurotoxic but we know methamphetamine
on its own is neurotoxic we also know
that people often will combine MDMA and
methamphetamine we also know that a lot
of so-called MDMA out there is mostly
methamphetamine with only a little bit
of MDMA so a study of the sort that I'm
about to describe where it is
essentially confirmed that people were
taking pure MDMA and not taking any
other drugs is of immense value this
study
has been a little bit controversial in
fact I've talked about it before I
talked about the Joe Rogan podcast I've
talked about it briefly with a guest on
this podcast Dr Nolan Williams who's a
triple board certified physician
psychiatrist and neurologist at Stanford
School of Medicine
and it's an interesting study and a
little bit controversial because it
relied on a population of people who
have taken MDMA anywhere from one to two
hundred times and who've not taken any
other drugs including caffeine and the
population in mind here is a population
of people living in Utah who
self-identify as members of the Church
of Latter-day Saints sometimes referred
to as Mormons sometimes referred to as
LDS or of the Church of Latter-day
Saints
the Church of Latter-day Saints as I
understand does not allow for
taking of certain compound certain drugs
certain certainly most recreational
drugs alcohol even caffeine and I'm sure
there's some variation on some of those
themes depending on where people live
and the certain communities that they
happen to be in I am in no way shape or
form
um declaring that I'm an expert on
Latter-Day Saints I have a couple of
friends who are LDS
happen to be very nice people as far as
I know they were not the people in this
study but this study really emphasized
ecstasy users they're called who have
not taken other drugs who self-identify
as LDS
and the major takeaway of this study was
that for moderate meaning people who
have taken ecstasy anywhere from 22 to
50 times
in their lifetime as well as heavy users
of MDMA so these are people who have
taken MDMA anywhere from 660 to 450
times in their lifetime
there was little evidence of decreased
cognitive performance in standard assays
for cognitive performance now there were
some effects showing poorer here I'm
quoting from the findings poor strategic
self-regulation
quote possibly reflecting increased
impulsivity however when you see a
conclusion like that you should
immediately be thinking chicken versus
egg right it could be that people that
are more impulsive and that have
less strategic self-regulation are more
likely to take ecstasy 450 times you
could conclude that or you could
conclude that people who have taken
ecstasy 75 times or 25 times Etc
are degrading their levels of
self-control and thereby increasing
impulsivity the direction of the effect
is not known these are purely
correlations nonetheless this study and
a few others like it really stand as our
best evidence believe it or not as to
how ecstasy taken many times because
after all these people are taken
anywhere from 22 to 450 doses of ecstasy
in their lifetime
is producing severe detriments in
cognitive performance and that simply
does not appear to be the case now
unfortunately there are no data looking
at the brains of these individuals
looking at for instance which brain
structures are active or less active or
perhaps even looking at levels of
Serotonin or dopamine all things that
can be done with positron emission
tomography Imaging functional MRI
Etc hopefully those studies will be done
in the not too distant future but if we
were to just take a step back from all
the data the data in mice in rats and
non-human primates the retraction of the
study in non-human primates which showed
that
the primates that showed
neurodegeneration were not given MDMA as
it was thought by the researchers but
rather as later was acknowledged we're
actually given methamphetamine and we
take into account these moderate and
heavy users of MDMA who as far as we
know are being honest and haven't taken
any other drugs
and we look at the clinical studies
where people who have never taken MDMA
are given one or two or three defined
doses of pure MDMA we'll talk about
those studies in a moment I think the
Gestalt the top Contour the overall view
of those studies is that provided it as
pure MDMA
and provided the individual is not
consuming other drugs which have the
potential to be neurotoxic
and provided that it's being done in a
controlled clinical setting the risk for
toxicity seems quite a bit lower than
the popular press has promoted and yet
there is still the risk of neurotoxicity
if people are taking high doses of MDMA
or taking it very frequently or
certainly if they are taking it in
conjunction with other drugs or or I
should say and or taking MDMA in
settings that can promote neurotoxicity
and the settings I'm referring to are
any settings in which blood pressure or
body temperature have the propensity to
be greatly increased every study in mice
in non-human primates and in humans in
which MDMA is administered has observed
significant increases in blood pressure
and heart rate MDMA is after all a
psychostimulant it's a sympathomimetic
talked about sympathomimetics and what
that means in the episode on Adderall
and Vyvanse and ADHD but basically it's
ramping up the activity of the
sympathetic nervous system which is your
fight or flight system okay this is why
people who take these drugs get big
pupils you know big pupils of the eyes
that's why they feel agitated they want
to talk a lot they feel like they want
to move a lot that's why people take it
to dance at Raves Etc but when people
take sympathomimetics whether or not
it's MDMA or amphetamine or cocaine or
even caffeine there's an increase in
blood pressure and heart rate but also
body temperature and if that's done in
an environment in which there's very
little temperature regulation so people
aren't for instance drinking enough
fluids and electrolytes it's very hot in
the room
you can get neurotoxicity based on
temperature effects and that's because
serotonin and dopamine also act on the
so-called medial pre-optic area of the
hypothalamus which is involved in
temperature regulation if you're curious
about temperature regulation I covered a
lot of that in the episodes of the
Hebrew and Lab podcast on deliberate
coal exposure and deliberate heat
exposure this is an area I used to work
on many years ago as a research
scientist before moving on to other
topics to research in my laboratory
big increases in body temperature are
not good the body and in particular your
brain can tolerate
decreases in body temperature that are
pretty robust and you can still stay
safe
you're not going to kill neurons but
even an increase of three or four
degrees in body temperature can start to
kill off neurons so when thinking about
the potential neurotoxicity of MDMA the
conditions that is the environmental
conditions the behavioral conditions
under which somebody takes MDMA are
vitally important at least important I
would argue as any other compounds they
might be ingesting with MDMA so that's
something really serious to consider so
if somebody says MDMA puts holes in your
brain you would be correct in being
skeptical or at least giving them some
counter Arguments for that statement but
if somebody says MDMA is not toxic well
then you would be equally valid in
saying ah wait but we need to think
about the conditions under which MDMA is
being taken is it pure MDMA or is it
mostly methamphetamine in which case it
would be very toxic is it MDMA alone or
in conjunction with caffeine within that
same 24-hour period is it MDMA while
moving around a lot or being outdoors or
being in an environment perhaps a rave
or dance type environment where
temperature is going up well in that
case it could be very neurotoxic so
pharmacology of MDMA counts but so does
poly pharmacology the ingestion of other
compounds
not just during the MDMA session but
also in the 24 hours before and after
that MDMA session and behaviors will
certainly impact temperature which will
impact whether or not MDMA is neurotoxic
or not and despite my efforts I couldn't
find out whether or not the LDS
Community has officially sanctioned the
use of MDMA certainly that's one
possibility but I have no evidence for
that or rather whether or not certain
people within the LDS Community have
allowed themselves given themselves
permission to use MDMA and they are not
using other drugs what I do understand
to be the case is that people within the
LDS Community are discouraged from using
drugs like caffeine or cocaine or
alcohol and this particular population
of people that was explored in this
study
self-identify as LDS and self-identify
as having taken MDMA anywhere from 22 to
450 times but where they got permission
for that whether or not it was from
someone else or from themselves I do not
know what I do know is that within the
acknowledgments of the paper there's
actually a thank you to the person that
identified this quote unique population
for our study
so I welcome you to take a look at the
paper and if any of you know more about
if and how a particular subgroup within
the LDS Community is allowed to take
MDMA perhaps you want to put those in
the comment section on YouTube before
moving to our discussion about what MDMA
is doing and the effects that people are
seeing in the clinical studies for the
treatment of PTSD which by the way are
extremely exciting I can't wait to share
these data with you I do want to touch
on something that anyone who's heard
about MDMA or perhaps used MDMA
is familiar with and that's the
so-called crash that people experience
after MDMA there are a lot of myths
about the post-mdma crash and there's a
lot of lore out there on the internet
about how to offset the crash and a lot
of lore about how to prevent the
potential neurotoxicity of MDMA earlier
we talked about some of the major points
around offsetting neurotoxicity so
certainly making sure that any MDMA that
one takes is in the legal clinical
setting that it's therefore pure MDMA
right that it's not cut with other
things which certainly can increase
toxicity controlling the temperature of
one's environment restricting caffeine
intake
at least on the day of MDMA ingestion
but certainly the day before and the day
after would be advantageous well simply
because of the way that caffeine and
activation of the adenosine receptor as
well as caffeine's effects on dopamine
receptors can interact with the
potential again potential neurotoxicity
of MDMA but the crash that one
experiences after MDMA is actually a
phenomenon very common to the crash that
one experiences after ingestion of any
type of stimulant cocaine amphetamine
Etc
and the crash that we're referring to is
a drop in mood increase in lethargy
feelings of lack of motivation many
people have wrongly assumed that the
crash was due to quote unquote depletion
of Serotonin or depletion of dopamine or
maybe even death of serotonergic and
dopaminergic neurons and while certainly
that could be the case it's very
unlikely that that would be the case in
the immediate 24 or 48 hours after MDMA
ingestion
that said you will see protocols that
people put out on the internet such as
oh you know after taking MDMA you should
take a bunch of you know 5-HTP or other
precursors to serotonin or dopamine
which come in amino acid forms so
L-tryptophan for instance is the
amino acid precursor to serotonin it's
in the serotonin synthesis pathway
you'll hear that people will take
l-tyrosine which is the amino acid
precursor to dopamine as a way to try
and buffer or increase dopamine during
the so-called period of the crash
there's really no evidence that any of
those things can be beneficial and there
is actually some reason to believe that
it might be detrimental because if
anything taking L-tryptophan and taking
l-tyrosine would actually further
deplete serotonin and dopamine so the
logic there is simply not very good what
is clear however is that MDMA can cause
not just profound increases in dopamine
serotonin and oxytocin but that anytime
there's a big increase in dopamine there
is going to be a post-dopominergic
increase in prolactin release and
prolactin is a hormone sometimes
considered a neural hormone but it's
really a hormone that's involved in a
lot of things milk let down in lactating
women it's involved in setting the
refractory period to sexual arousal
and erection and ejaculation in males
after ejaculation it's involved in lots
of different functions in the brain and
body including the laying down of body
fat stores and it's also associated with
increases in lethargy decreases in
dopamine this is why drugs that increase
dopamine are known to decrease prolactin
at least in the short term this is wise
drugs like cabergoline for instance that
increase dopamine are used as ways to
suppress prolactin now MDMA ingestion is
known to dramatically increase prolactin
and people are starting to realize that
it perhaps is the increase in prolactin
that occurs both during and for some
period of time probably hours or days
after ingestion of MDMA that leads to at
least some components of the so-called
crash that feeling of lethargy and lack
of motivation maybe diminished mood Etc
and for that reason some people have
started to explore the use of things
like p5p which is essentially a
metabolite of vitamin B6 which is known
to suppress prolactin
as a way to try and buffer some of that
crash to my knowledge there are no human
data yet exploring the use of p5p or
other vitamin B6 derivatives or
capergoline or things of that sort to
reduce prolactin in a controlled
standardized clinical trial kind of
manner but I've spoken to some of the
clinicians that are using MDMA legally
within the context of the treatment of
PTSD and this is an area that's starting
to receive some additional attention so
I just mentioned it briefly here because
for instance there's a lot of ideas out
there that people should be taking
L-tryptophan they should be taking
l-tyrosine they should be taking
magnesium other things Etc after taking
MDMA in order to recover from the
post-mdma crash more quickly
but it's really the increase in
prolactin which speaks most directly to
the subjective effects of the so-called
crash so by my read of the mechanisms of
MDMA the neurochemicals it releases the
neural hormones that it promotes the
release of prolactin in particular this
p5p suppression of prolactin is perhaps
the one that's most intriguing and that
really has any kind of mechanistic basis
so I promise that going forward as the
scientists and clinicians that are using
MDMA for the treatment of PTSD and other
conditions such as alcohol use disorder
Etc
start to explore the use of post-mdma
session p5p and other modes of
suppressing prolactin for the hours and
days after MDMA promise to update you on
those findings throughout today's
episode I've been referring to clinical
studies that is clinical trials
exploring the use of MDMA in order to
augment treatment for PTSD
so let's just take a moment and talk
about what PTSD is PTSD is
post-traumatic stress disorder
trauma is anything that modifies the
brain to function less well going
forward you know physical trauma you can
have emotional trauma typically PTSD is
used to refer to emotional trauma caused
by either single events so you can
imagine you know car accident sexual
assault
these could be first person experiences
so things that happen to somebody that
leads to trauma and then PTSD these can
also be third person events where
someone observes something that is
traumatic to them
maybe somebody being killed dismembered
any number of different things that
could be very traumatic in the immediate
and long term and of course
PTSD need not be caused only by single
event traumas but by multiple event
traumas entire relationships entire
childhoods wartime experiences
combinations of different traumas and on
and on there are so many different forms
of trauma if any of you are interested
in trauma and its treatment I highly
recommend the book trauma by Dr Paul
Conte he's an MD medical doctor
psychiatrist he was featured as a guest
on this podcast he's been on a number of
other prominent podcasts we will provide
a link in our show note captions to the
book trauma I consider that book to be
the best book in terms of describing
what trauma is and isn't and how it
leads to PTSD it also describes some of
Dr Paul Conti's own experiences with
trauma and his own treatment of trauma
in his patient population which is quite
wide-ranging men women young people
older people and a variety of traumatic
experiences so excellent book for those
of you interested in trauma
now the treatment of trauma has been met
with some degree of Success Through
quality talk therapy
let's Define quality talk therapy in the
way that Dr Paul Conti did on this
episode that's talk therapy for which
the patient sometimes referred to as the
client but more traditionally referred
to as the patient and the therapist so a
psychologist or psychiatrist has Good
Rapport and as a consequence of that
Rapport there is the feeling of support
that there is a safe place in which to
explore the trauma and what's happening
in one's current life in order to
understand how that trauma is fitting
into adaptive and maladaptive behaviors
and emotional states
now in addition to Rapport and support
being critical there's a third component
of effective talk therapy for trauma
which is Insight or one's ability to
come to an understanding of why one
feels the way they do
and to link that to some larger context
that brings about some degree of relief
and that's where things start to get a
little bit abstract and that's also
where we start to see that while trauma
therapy in the form of talk therapy can
be very effective about half of people
that undergo talk therapy and talk
therapy alone for the treatment of PTSD
achieve no long-lasting relief of
symptoms and an even smaller number of
them undergo complete remittance of
their PTSD okay so their symptoms can
lessen they can get some improvement but
that Improvement is often slight or is
transient and for those that do achieve
relief it's often not complete remission
of the PTSD itself
now in addition to talk therapy for PTSD
there is of course prescription drug
therapies and most often these fall
under the category of ssris selective
serotonin reuptake Inhibitors and it's
well known that ssris can be in limited
circumstances effective for the
treatment of PTSD
it has been shown for instance that as
many as 40 maybe as many as 60 of people
that take ssris for the treatment of
PTSD get some symptom relief
now that is not to say that ssris don't
have side effects they can have side
effects some of you are probably
familiar with these side effects things
like blunting of libido blunting of
appetite or increases in appetite in
some cases disruption of sleep wake
rhythms motivation Etc so there's often
an exploration for the so-called minimal
effective dose that provides some
symptom relief to PTSD but that doesn't
introduce unwanted side effects and of
course there's a third situation where
people are taking ssris and doing talk
therapy for PTSD and what's very clear
is that anytime you add quality talk
therapy to a drug treatment you're going
to improve the outcomes for that drug
treatment
the reverse is not always true it's not
always the case that adding prescription
drug treatment to talk therapy improves
outcomes for talk therapy although that
has been observed in a number of studies
now the whole idea of exploring the use
of MDMA for the treatment of PTSD stem
from the fact that even in people who
are getting quality talk therapy and
again we can Define quality talk therapy
as
Good Rapport between patient and
clinician as well as feelings of support
as well as potential insight
and even when ssris are combined with
that quality talk therapy there's still
a large number of people who simply do
not achieve significant or long-lasting
relief from their PTSD and an even fewer
number who go into full remittance of
their PTSD that is despite being
diligent and hardworking in their talk
therapy despite the therapist being very
committed despite the use of ssris in
conjunction with a talk therapy those
people often still qualify as having
PTSD and the goal of course is for
somebody to receive treatment that
allows them to no longer meet the
criteria for having PTSD
not just in terms of a clinical
evaluation but that they themselves
report feeling much better not feeling
overwhelmed with the symptomology of
PTSD now the symptomology for PTSD is
vast and it's far too vast to go into
into a lot of detail right now I think
most people are familiar with a
stereotyped example of PTSD this is the
soldier that comes back from overseas
that has been in gun fights or in
battles of different kinds has likely
seen casualties and severe injuries and
that upon return to a safe environment
is still experiencing a lot of anxiety
and sometimes panic attacks that occur
seemingly at random or they can be
sparked by you know the classic
stereotyped example is you know a car
backfires and then the person suddenly
feels as if they're back in battle that
sort of thing does happen certainly but
there are a whole other category of
symptoms of PTSD which include
dissociative symptoms of PTSD people who
have PTSD from very intensely traumatic
experiences that um are checked out they
don't feel like they can engage they
have brain fog they are distracted they
go from feeling anxious to feeling
exhausted they have sleep issues not
surprisingly then people with PTSD of
either the dissociative type or other
symptomology of PTSD and keep in mind
that one can have both dissociative and
non-dissociative symptoms of PTSD such
as anxiety and panic
are at a far greater risk of substance
abuse so the current estimates are that
people with PTSD no matter what type of
PTSD dissociative symptoms or or
otherwise you know panic attacks or both
are at a much greater risk of having
addictions to either illicit drugs or
prescription drugs or both so things
like alcohol use disorder is very common
in people with PTSD opioid use disorder
is very common stimulant use disorder
and on and on so people with PTSD suffer
at a number of different levels and
there are all these what are called
comorbidities with PTSD including
addiction but also depression anxiety
and so you can start to see how ptst
sets up a whole Cascade of things that
make living life extremely problematic
at the level of basic relationships
functioning in the workplace
and even when mental health appears to
be in check oftentimes people are
holding a lot in so they have
cardiovascular and cerebral vascular
deficits that cause a lot of problems in
their immediate and long-term physical
health so PTSD is a very serious issue
the current estimates are that as many
as eight percent of people in the United
States have PTSD and again the estimates
around comorbidities range anywhere from
you know 17 to 46 or as high as 65
percent of people with PTSD having
comorbidities for other mental health
issues and addiction in particular
so finding lasting relief to PTSD is
extremely important and made even more
important by the fact that many people
with PTSD sadly end up committing
suicide so suicide rates are far greater
in people with PTSD the exact rates of
increase and suicidality in people with
PTSD
are a little bit hard to arrive at in
the statistics because of all the
comorbidities but suffice to say that
suicide is far more likely in people
with PTSD along with all the other
issues that PTSD brings about now PTSD
creates all the problems that it does
largely through changes in brain
circuitry as well as neural
communication between the brain and body
many people have perhaps heard of the
book the body keeps the score which is a
very successful and popular book about
the idea that trauma can be quote
unquote stored in the body to be clear
traumas can't actually be stored in the
body you don't actually store memories
in the body
what you store are activation of neural
circuits that include brain and body and
they all seem to Center back into the
insula that structure that we talked
about earlier this structure in our
brain that has a map of our body's
surface so contrary to popular belief we
don't store memories in the body or
trauma in the body in a way that for
instance working out a knot or a pain in
one's lower back will relieve the trauma
it sometimes can activate a memory of
the trauma but when one is doing that
what you're really doing is activating
neural circuits that reside within the
brain within the insula that correspond
to Sensations within the body now I
don't want to diminish the role of the
body and the formation and the
Persistence of PTSD and I certainly
think the book the body keeps the score
is a pioneering book it's in fact an
important book uh but I want to
emphasize that the modern Neuroscience
really points to the fact that PTSD is
caused by the exact sorts of brain
Network activations that we were
discussing earlier things like
heightened levels of activation in the
amygdala to insulate pathway which of
course would exacerbate bodily
Sensations related to the trauma or
heightened activation of the hippocampus
this memory Center in the brain too
amygdala to insula circuitry now
therefore it should come as no surprise
that if MDMA can reduce the levels of
activity in the hippocampal to amygdala
to insula circuitry and can do so both
while someone is under the effects of
MDMA but then lead to persistent
long-lasting reductions in the
activation of those brain networks well
then it stands to reason that MDMA could
be a valid therapeutic for the treatment
of PTSD and of course this has been
explored and here we can really give a
nod and
large debt of gratitude to the so-called
maps group the maps group is a group
that's operating mainly out of Santa
Cruz California but they have a number
of different satellite Laboratories and
clinical groups both in the US in Canada
and abroad where they've worked with
government organizations to get legal
authorization
to give MDMA to patients who have PTSD
to also give them talk therapy and then
to compare the effects of talk therapy
with MDMA to talk therapy with Placebo
alone and there are about three to five
studies in this area now that stand as
large-scale clinical trials that are
showing what can only be described as
remarkable results for the treatment of
PTSD so rather than going to any one of
those studies in immense detail I'm
going to summarize across those studies
I will provide links to those in the
show note captions
the two that I think are most
interesting are the study entitled MDMA
assisted therapy for severe PTSD a
randomized double-blind
placebo-controlled phase three study as
well as the study entitled the effects
of MDMA assisted therapy on alcohol and
substance use in a phase 3 trial for the
treatment of severe TSD so as the title
suggests both clinical trials involve
giving people talk therapy and MDMA or
talk therapy and placebo
talk about exactly how that was done in
a moment and then to look at relief of
PTSD symptoms but also relief of some of
the addictive symptoms that are commonly
associated with PTSD so just to give you
an overview of what's happening with
these trials and why there's so much
excitement and why we really are on the
cusp of legalization of MDMA for the
treatment of PTSD in the sorts of
clinical context I described
when people are given just talk therapy
alone or talk therapy with ssris
they will often as I mentioned earlier
experience reductions in their severity
of PTSD symptoms and rarely they will
experience complete remittance of their
PTSD that is they will no longer qualify
for PTSD after receiving a number of
talk therapy sessions
so let's compare that to what happens
when people do talk therapy in
conjunction with MDMA and I'll explain
exactly what that means in a moment but
it essentially means taking MDMA while
doing talk therapy however this is a
very important however the people who
are taking MDMA in these trials have
already done talk therapy without MDMA
then they're doing talk therapy under
the influence of MDMA and then they are
doing sessions of talk therapy not under
the influence of MDMA and the entire
time they're doing that with the same
two therapists okay in the placebo group
people are doing talk therapy with two
therapists
but they're not taking MDMA okay so
they're doing the same number of therapy
sessions but they're not taking MDMA so
to just get to the key numbers first
the overall rate for clinically
effective response to MDMA assisted
therapy is 88 that's what's emerging
from these trials versus 60 for the
placebo
and therapy alone so on the face of it
you might say okay wow 88 of people who
do talk therapy and here I might as well
just finally explain how this is done
patients are selected because they have
PTSD they meet the clinical criteria for
PTSD
they do three 90-minute therapy sessions
with two therapists talking about their
PTSD symptoms talking about to the
extent that they can the incident that
or incidents the life events that led to
that PTSD
none of that is done under the influence
of any drug okay so everyone in the
experiment does that then
the group divides into two where half
are taking MDMA
they take that
three times
during those three times they are also
receiving therapy sessions with the same
therapists that they were working with
before they took MDMA
the first session they're taking 80
milligrams of MDMA and then a 40
milligram booster about an hour and a
half to two hours in
the second session they are taking a
higher dose of MDMA it's 120 milligrams
and then if they elect to they can take
a 60 milligram booster about an hour and
a half to two hours into the session
and then there's a third session where
they take again 120 milligrams of MDMA
and have the option to take a 60
milligram booster about an hour and a
half to two hours into the session again
anytime they're on MDMA they have
therapists there
that they're talking to about their
trauma they are either spending time
with their eyes closed lying down
sometimes in an eye mask and thinking
about the trauma thinking about their
current state and experience
also thinking about what happened before
then they're exiting the eye mask or
talking to the therapist therapist is
taking notes asking questions remember
they've established a strong Rapport
supportive relationship with these
therapists prior to taking MDMA in the
therapy session
and then they also undergo three
90-minute therapy sessions with the two
therapists spaced one week apart after
the final MDMA session now those that
were placed into the placebo condition
do everything exactly the same as I just
described so three 90-minute sessions as
prep then three
eight hour sessions with those two
therapists
and then three 90-minute follow-up
sessions one week apart but they take a
placebo
not MDMA so you can see that in these
so-called Maps studies these clinical
trials for PTSD the conditions are very
similar except for the inclusion of the
drug MDMA
so those rates of success with talk
therapy and MDMA again overall rate for
clinically effective response to MDMA
assisted therapy was 88 compared to 60
percent for therapy and placebo
what's even more impressive however is
that 67 percent of the people in the
MDMA plus therapy treatment group no
longer met the criteria for PTSD by the
end of the treatment so in other words
their PTSD went into remittance now we
could say they are quote unquote cured
but typically for things like PTSD
that's not the language that's used
rather what's used is statistical
evaluation of how the different symptoms
like dissociation or anxiety or Sleep
Disorders are explored so while to some
of you a difference between 60 percent
success with talk therapy and Placebo
versus 88 success with talk therapy plus
MDMA might not seem like that big of a
difference it is indeed quite an
enormous difference in fact to my
knowledge there is no other example of a
treatment for a psychiatric disorder
that is successful to the same magnitude
I could be wrong about that I'm sure
some psychiatrists out there are going
to jump on me about this and please do I
would encourage you if you are aware of
any therapy plus drug treatment that is
effective at rates of greater than 88
percent for the treatment of a major
psychiatric disorder please do put that
information in the comments on YouTube
and perhaps a reference to a study would
be even better but even if not just put
a reference to that that would be great
for sake of future episodes Etc but
nonetheless an 88 percent
success rate and here I'm referring to
success rate as a significant reduction
in clinical symptoms for PTSD and 67 of
those people going into full remittance
for PTSD by the end of the treatment is
pretty spectacular which is why you're
hearing so much these days about the
potential transition of MDMA from a
schedule one drug for which there are
quote unquote No clinical applications
to potentially a legal within the
context of clinical use application of
MDMA which it does appear the
legislature is at least considering for
as early as 2024 maybe even later in
2023 it remains to be seen now a number
of other important results have emerged
from this and other clinical trials for
instance
remember earlier I talked about how many
people with PTSD also suffer from
alcohol use disorder what's interesting
is that for people that were in the MDMA
plus talk Therapy Group in this and
other studies
who also had patterns of alcohol use
disorder and even some other substance
use disorders the MDMA plus talk therapy
treatment
in many cases resolved their addiction
to alcohol or other symptoms as well and
perhaps that shouldn't be surprising if
we think about the addictions as
stemming directly from their PTSD but it
is surprising if you think about the
fact that alcohol use disorder and some
other addictive disorders
oftentimes will stem from disruptions in
neural circuitry that
are the same disruptions in neural
circuitry that occur in PTSD but often
are the consequence of entirely other
brain wiring phenomenon what I'm saying
here is that just because addiction and
PTSD are often co-morbid with one
another
it was not necessarily the case that
treating and resolving PTSD would
resolve the alcohol or substance abuse
disorder and yet that seems to be the
case often not always but often in these
successful treatments of PTSD so that's
very exciting some of the other
particularly exciting results from these
clinical trials on MDMA plus talk
therapy is that the dissociative form of
PTSD has traditionally proved to be
especially hard to treat and that's
thought to stem from the fact that
successful treatment of PTSD whether or
not it's by talk therapy or talk therapy
combined with ssris or talk therapy
combined with any drug treatment or
behavioral treatment like EMDR eye
movement desensitization reprogramming
or other forms of treatments that are
designed to rewire neural circuitry
almost always involve the patient
getting very close to or at least
reporting the traumatic experiences in a
lot of detail and you can imagine why
for somebody who's dissociating from
that very experience who's quote unquote
checked out and can't really seem to
access the emotional states and the
memories
because they're blocked off from them or
because they're unwilling to access
those memories and really think about
the full emotional capacity of those
memories that it would be particularly
hard to bring them through any kind of
treatment for PTSD so it appears that
MDMA in providing this pro-social
empathic again empathic for others and
empathic for self chemical and kind of
mental environment as well as the
presence of two trusted therapists which
one has a really good rapport
allows patients with PTSD to really get
close to those experiences that were
traumatic to talk about them and to
think about them and in many ways to
reframe them in a context that often
involves empathy for others and empathy
for self now here we're not necessarily
talking about forgiveness of
perpetrators although that's sometimes
the case that people will forgive the
person that inflicted the trauma on them
but more often than not it's about tying
their feelings of trauma and their
feelings of depression anxiety
dissociation Etc to some sort of larger
context that allows them to see
themselves in the role of agency to be
in the role of knowing that yes these
things happened and yet by getting close
to the emotional load of those things
and really being in many ways unafraid
to get close to the emotional load of
that and having support around that that
the emotional load seems diminished and
that they experience the emotional load
of those experiences as diminished both
within the MDMA treatment session and
afterwards for long periods of time so
essentially what happens is these people
feel that what once burdened them they
can still remember but it no longer
burdens them it no longer feels like
it's in their body and in their mind or
on Loop or on repeat in a way that's
invasive in a way that interferes with
other aspects of normal functioning so
when one hears about these kinds of
results and when you hear about some of
the patient reports and I invite you to
do that you can go to the map site which
by the way is recruiting subjects for
these clinical trials and you'll also
find reports of individuals who
participated in these clinical trials
and of course we will provide links to
these incredible clinical trials that
Maps has spearheaded what you find is
that
the combination of MDMA and talk therapy
in many ways is not about the drug
having a particular effect it's really
about the drug having a particular
effect that allows the motivations and
the results of talk therapy to really be
heightened and I think that's a really
key point to make because up until now
we've really been talking about the
neurochemistry of MDMA the potential
toxicity or lack thereof of MDMA we've
been talking about that brain networks
Etc but when one thinks about the valid
clinical use of MDMA for the treatment
of PTSD and I should mention
it also had some success in dealing with
not only alcohol use disorders and other
use disorders associated with PTSD but
also relieving the depression associated
with PTSD so now MDMA is being explored
for treatment of not just PTSD but also
for depression for alcohol use disorder
and for eating disorders as well
MDMA seems to be a compound that
produces the right kind of subjective
and neurochemical milieu in the brain
that allows therapy to be that much more
potent within a limited number of
sessions and when one thinks about the
cost of mental health care you know how
expensive it is to get therapy over and
over and over again which in ideal
circumstances people are able to do that
either by way of insurance or by their
own finances or you know I I don't want
to say that the cost of therapy should
be reduced because of course therapists
have to survive also but the idea here
is that people who are suffering would
be able to achieve relief from their
PTSD their depression their addiction
and to be able to do so by hopefully
persisting in their therapy over
whatever period of time is required but
also to assume a circumstance in which
somebody only has
10 or 15 or maybe even just three
opportunities to undergo treatment for
PTSD and nonetheless is able to achieve
tremendous relief during the session and
after the session and it really does
seem to be the case that for reasons
that you now understand the activation
of particular brain networks the
suppression of other brain networks in
particular this amygdala to
insulopathway that when people are under
the influence of MDMA in these very safe
and therapeutic supportive settings they
are able to look at traumatic events and
the ways that those traumatic events
impact them in ways that really allow
them to cognitively reframe those events
and somatically reframe those events to
really change the way that it lives in
their body and mind so that it's no
longer invasive and then they can go on
and Lead productive adaptive lives and
as a final Point related to these
clinical studies I of course would be
remiss if I didn't touch on some of the
so-called adverse effects because
anytime there's a drug or talk therapy
for a mental health issue Adverse Events
have to be considered and I think it's
quite reassuring that in the case of
MDMA therapy there were no increases in
the number of suicide attempts or
suicidality or obsession with suicide
contrast that with the group that
received Placebo where there were a
certain number of Baseline and predicted
obsessions with suicide fortunately at
least to my knowledge there was no
actual suicide attempt or successful
suicide thankfully but the point being
that the addition of MDMA drug therapy
to PTSD talk therapy does not seem to
increase the quote-unquote side effects
that are sometimes associated with PTSD
talk therapy because indeed there can be
side effects to exploring PTSD and
Trauma as one would expect
so overall I would say it's very
exciting times for the exploration of
MDMA as an augmented talk therapy for
the treatment of PTSD and these other
conditions again I think the maps group
has done a remarkable job of keeping
this within the realm of legal and
trying to move things forward in terms
of legislation to make sure that MDMA
isn't simply made legal and then abused
recreationally I know people out there
have different views on whether or not
drugs like MDMA should be legal or not
that's not what this episode is about
what I am very excited about as you can
probably tell what I think a lot of
people in the psychology and Psychiatry
Community are very excited about you say
the Mental Health Community at large is
that these compounds that for many years
we're only associated with their
recreational uses and therefore
were not well understood because they
were often contaminated or taken in
combination with other things or by
people that never
should have been taking them in the
first place
taken by young kids which is a whole
other matter you know a lot of issues
and problems associated with these
compounds and yet
we're now seeing from these clinical
trials when used
say properly because really when safety
Protocols are obeyed when there's
clinical support it is very clear that
when MDMA is combined with quality talk
therapy that the outcomes are looking
tremendously positive it's by no means a
miracle cure it is by no means perfect
and time will tell what problems if any
arise from the short or long-term use of
mdama in this context but I think it's
remarkable that anywhere from two to
three sessions with MDMA and talk
therapy have been shown to significantly
reduce PTSD symptoms and in some cases
completely eliminate PTSD symptoms in
such a wide range of patients and in
patients that have experienced both PTSD
and these other comorbid disorders I
think it's really remarkable it's very
exciting and I look forward to seeing
what the next round of data produce so
as is often the case on this podcast
today we went into a lot of detail about
a subject MDMA is this incredible
compound synthesized as far as we know
first by humans not by plants not by
aliens but by humans
and that produces big increases in
dopamine and serotonin to create these
highly motivated pro-social empathic
States
meaning both empathy for others and for
self and that when applied in the
context of psychiatric challenges like
PTSD and addiction is proving to create
a lot of relief for a lot of people
where other forms of drug therapy or
combination drug and talk therapy had
failed before
we talked about some of the potential
neurotoxicity issues I don't think that
is a resolved issue just yet although
the bulk of data in humans and non-human
primates point to the fact that at
reasonable Doses and we talked earlier
about what those are at reasonable doses
when not combined with other drugs it
does not appear that MDMA is exceedingly
neurotoxic and it may not be neurotoxic
at all of course one needs to be
exceedingly cautious when thinking about
the use of any sympathomimetic
they of course can be neurotoxic
anything with methamphetamine in it has
a potential to be neurotoxic but of
course dosage matters context matters we
talked about that and of course
the purity of drug matters and again I
just want to re-emphasize the fentanyl
contamination of MDMA that sold on the
street and that is being used
recreational is of very serious
potentially lethal concern I also expect
that there will be a lot of interest in
these clinical trials that Maps is doing
so again you can find links to that in
the show note captions and I think in
general
we should acknowledge that we are a very
interesting and important time in human
history for the treatment of psychiatric
disorders and for Neuroscience generally
because whether or not we're talking
about psilocybin or LSD or Ayahuasca or
ketamine or today's topic of MDMA
regardless of what drug and
neurotransmitter neuromodulator systems
are involved what we're really talking
about are ways to access neuroplasticity
the nervous system's incredible ability
to modify itself in response to
experience ideally to be modified in
adaptive ways that make it function
better so that's really the Crux of what
talk therapy and drug therapies are
about that's what the goal of using MDMA
as a clinical tool is all about and in
that sense I find MDMA to be an
incredibly interesting and important
topic and I hope you did as well if
you're learning from and or enjoying
this podcast please subscribe to our
YouTube channel that's a terrific zero
cost way to support us in addition
please subscribe to the podcast on both
Spotify and apple and on both Spotify
and apple you can leave us up to a
five-star review if you have questions
for me or comments about the podcast or
guests that you'd like me to interview
on The huberman Lab podcast please put
those in the comment section on YouTube
I do read all the comments please also
check out the sponsors mentioned at the
beginning and throughout today's episode
that's the best way to support this
podcast
not so much during today's episode but
on many previous episodes of The
huberman Lab podcast we discuss
supplements while supplements aren't
necessary for everybody many people
derive tremendous benefit from them for
things like improving sleep for hormone
support and for Focus the huberman Lab
podcast is proud to have partnered with
momentous supplements if you'd like to
see the supplements discussed on the
huberman Lab podcast you can go to live
momentous spelled ous so that's
livemomentis.com huberman if you're not
already following me on social media I
am a huberman lab on Instagram Twitter
Facebook and Linkedin and at all those
places I discuss science and science
related tools for mental health physical
health and performance some of which
overlap with the science and tools that
are discussed on the huberman Lab
podcast but much of which is distinct
from the information covered on the
huberman Lab podcast so again it's
huberman lab on all social media
platforms if you haven't already
subscribed to our neural network
newsletter the neural network newsletter
is a monthly newsletter it's completely
zero cost where we provide podcast
summaries as well as toolkits the tool
kits are short lists in PDF form of
things that you can do to improve for
instance sleep or neuroplasticity or
dopamine regulation or deliberate cold
exposure or Fitness and on and on again
all of that is available at zero cost
you simply go to hubermanlab.com go to
the menu scroll down to newsletter and
provide your email we do not share your
email with anybody so if you're
interested in those toolkits and the
neural network newsletter again that's
available at hubermanlab.com thank you
again for joining me for today's
discussion all about MDMA and last but
certainly not least thank you for your
interest in science
[Music]